du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par Monsieur Philippe
Vigier pour le groupe démocrate merci
madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Christophe Béchy
le ministre de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre entre
les 27 juin et le 6 juillet il y a eu
des très nombreuses dégradations des
violences très fort dans ce pays et nous
les avons quasiment unanimement
condamnée je regrette que quelques amis
de Monsieur Mélenchon ne l'ai pas fait
ces violences et faisaient suite vous le
savez à la mort de sujet de Naël et
c'est violent elles ont touché des
symboles de la république des écoles des
bibliothèques des mairies même un bus
médicalisé c'est violence sont
inacceptables parce que elles sont le
fait de certains qui veulent le chaos
mais il n'y a pas de place pour le chaos
alors monsieur le ministre qui a été
également indigné des voir que le
week-end dernier des députés insoumis
étaient présents et manifestation
interdite parce que lorsqu'on vote la
loi en semaine on la respecte le
week-end alors monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre il s'agit
maintenant de reconstruire ces symboles
de la république de faire en sorte que
ces bâtiments publics ces lieux
d'accueil on soit capable demain de
montrer que c'est pas l'impuissance que
tu as rendez-vous mieux au contraire
l'efficacité calories vous faire en
matière d'urbanisme pour simplifier des
procédures qu'allez-vous faire en
matière de financement pour les
fluidifier qu'allez-vous faire en
matière de règles de marché public pour
rendre possible ce qui est nécessaire
car l'urgence est là sans oublier les
copropriétés où on est souvent réduit à
l'impuissance monsieur le ministre
d'ailleurs ce texte ce qui est important
c'est de montrer que la République est
là que la République ne lâchera pas
qu'il n'y a pas de place pour le chaos
et que cette république elle exige que
chacun respecte les lois et que chacun
aide celles et ceux qui comme les mers
sont en première ligne et ont été
exemplaires comme le soulignant encore
le président Matéi la semaine dernière
j'attends vos réponses merci monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
recevant les mers des plusieurs
centaines de communes touchées par les
dégradations par les
incendies par les démolitions d'une
partie des bâtiments le président de la
République a pris un engagement celui
que nous puissions évoquer un texte
d'urgence pour accélérer cette
reconstruction
le Parlement sera soumis d'un projet de
loi d'habilité sur ordonnance qui sera
présentée au Conseil des ministres qui
comprendra trois articles 1 pour
accélérer sur l'aménagement un pour
faciliter les règles en termes de
commande publique et le troisième pour
poser la question des financements
d'abord sur la reconstruction faire en
sorte que dès que on fait une
déclaration préalable de travaux on
puisse commencer ses travaux faire en
sorte si le bâtiment a été totalement
détruit que la reconstruction à
l'identique puisse se faire même si
entre temps il y a une modification du
pluie et faire en sorte que le silence
de l'administration va approbation dans
le cas d'avis qui serait rendu
obligatoire ensuite en termes de
commandes publiques favoriser jusqu'à un
million d'euros
sans publicité mais avec comparaison des
offres le fait de pouvoir accélérer la
commande de travaux pour qu'en
particulier les dizaines d'écoles qui
ont été incendiées par les émeutiers
puissent réaccueillir dès la rentrée les
enfants qui étaient habituellement
accueillis dans ses écoles enfin faire
en sorte d'un point de vue budgétaire de
faire deux choses attendues par les mers
que le fond de compensation de la TVA
puisse être récupéré dès cette année
pour éviter qu'il y ait des avances de
trésorerie et supprimer la nécessité qui
est au moins 20% de reste à charge pour
les collectivités pour pouvoir imaginer
contre les assurances les conseils
régionaux les conseils départementaux et
l'État on puisse aller vers un reste à
charge zéro ce qui va se passer dans les
prochaines semaines monsieur le député
Vigier c'est précisément un rendez-vous
un rendez-vous pour faire en sorte que
nos condamnations quasi unanimes dans
cette hémicique de ces violences elle
s'accompagne par les moyens concrets de
pouvoir permettre au maire de restaurer
les services publics le plus vite
possible merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Julien audoul
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
des émeutes de Vaulx-en-Velin en 1990 à
l'embrasement des banlieues en 2005 tout
le monde pouvait prévoir ce qu'elle
allait se passer tout le monde sauf
Emmanuel Macron même votre ami Gérard
Collomb vous avez averti à son départ du
ministère de l'Intérieur en déclarant
aujourd'hui on vit côte à côte je crains
que demain on vive face à face demain
c'est aujourd'hui avec près de 24000
feux sur la voie publique plus de 12000
véhicules incendiés 2500 bâtiments
flammes ou dégradés plus de 7000
policiers gendarmes blessés en Guyane un
homme innocent est mort tué sur son
balcon par une balle de 9 mm tiré par un
émeutier qui visait les policiers la
victime s'appelait Karl Tarade je veux
lui rendre hommage
alors que vous aviez promis 100 jours
d'apaisement les Français ont subi cinq
nuits de chaos et de terreur face à
l'ampleur de ce déchaînement de violence
votre gouvernement a choisi de sortir
l'artillerie de carnaval et la matraque
de guignols avec la rédaction d'un flyer
à destination des parents la restriction
des réseaux sociaux ou encore
l'interdiction de la vente de mortier
d'artifice pour le 14 juillet les
Français en ont assez de votre déni de
réalité et de votre impuissance
chronique 65% des français demandent des
sanctions contre les parents de mineurs
multiréstidivistes avec la suspension
des allocations qu'attendez-vous pour
agir 69% des français demandent la
suspension de l'excuse de minorité pour
les mineurs qui participent aux émeutes
qu'attendez-vous pour agir
74% des Français considèrent qu'il y a
trop d'immigrés en France
qu'attendez-vous pour agir madame la
Première ministre qu'attendez-vous pour
écouter les Français
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Julien audoul nous n'avons pas attendu
pour agir 45000 forces de l'ordre
déployées dans toutes les villes du
territoire national par contre Monsieur
le Député vous n'attendez jamais pour
commenter pour généraliser pour
calomnier pour faire de la petite
politique monsieur le député et c'est à
ça qu'on vous reconnaît quand vous
parlez de guignols et de carnaval en
parlant des 45000 forces de sécurité
intérieure en parlant des pompiers en
parlant de toutes les personnes qui se
sont déployées sur le territoire qui ont
rétabli et qui ont maintenu l'ordre dans
les quartiers nuits après nuit en
évitant de faire des victimes
collatérales monsieur député
exprimez-vous mieux parce que je crois
que tout le monde a compris comme moi
ici
tout le monde a compris que vous vouliez
vous monsieur le député qu'on réunissent
le Parlement qu'on dotte Madame Le Pen
des pleins pouvoirs ne rêvez pas ça
n'arrivera pas votre réaction votre
réaction du groupe rassemblement
national montre bien ce qu'il y a
derrière votre question monsieur député
nous cherchons l'unité de la nation nous
cherchons l'ordre nous cherchons des
responsabilités et nous cherchons à
sanctionner tous ceux qui doivent l'être
oui nous parlons de responsabilité
parentale et nous avons raison de parler
de responsabilité parentale parce que si
nous ne le faisions pas nous passerions
à côté d'un problème sociétal grave qui
fait que des enfants de 12 ans ont
parfois pu au milieu de la nuit des
soirs d'émeutes se baladaient avec des
des briquets ou des armes à la main pour
les dégrader les bâtiments publics oui
nous parlons de la circulaire pénale
pour que la justice ait pu être rendue
de manière efficace y compris les
dimanches avec des dizaines de
comparution immédiates et à la clé des
peines de prison ferme c'est l'exemple
qui a été aussi envoyé à ces jeunes à
ses yeux métiers et qui les a aussi
dissuadés de continuer monsieur député
nous nous battons ici pour l'ordre au
fond vous vous battez pour le désordre
parce que c'est votre beurre c'est votre
miel les Français ne sont pas dupe merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre monsieur
Odoul quel indigence monsieur Véran très
clairement les Français n'attendent et
n'attendront rien de vous vivement 2027
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme Guedj
pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à vous madame la Première
ministre à en croire les journaux et
certains de vos ministres c'est
peut-être la dernière fois que vous vous
pliez à cet exercice des questions au
gouvernement à vrai dire les Français
sont fichent ce n'est pas le casting qui
compte mais le récit et les actes que
vous posez nous les cherchons en vain
après la désastreuse adoption au forceps
de la contre-réforme des retraites vous
avez donc bricoler avec le président
Macron les 100 jours nous y voilà pour
quel résultat vous vouliez gagner du
temps pour vous-même vous en avez fait
perdre au pays et aux Français alors
vous nous dites on a délivré on a
délivré reprenant la novlangue
managériale de vos chers cabinets de
conseils mais vous avez délivré quoi au
juste qui change la vie des gens pour
reprendre vos propres mots vous
promettiez aux Français 100 jours
d'apaisement vous les avez plongés un
peu plus dans l'épuisement et puis face
à l'inflation et à la crise du pouvoir
d'achat épuisement social évidemment
après la réforme des retraites
épuisement face à la crise des services
publics de la police à l'hôpital ou dans
les deux cas vous refusez de questionner
les moyens les méthodes d'intervention
les
l'organisation alors même que la mort de
Naël comme la fermeture des urgences
devrait vous obliger à repenser ses
services publics et évidemment
épuisement de nos ressources de notre
biodiversité de notre qualité de vie
face à l'inaction climatique comme si
cela ne suffisait pas vous avez ajouté
un épuisement démocratique toujours plus
de verticalité et la promesse enterrée
de légiférer autrement refusant par
exemple nos propos de nos propositions
transpartizanes sur les déserts médicaux
avec guillaume-garo sur EDF avec
Philippe Brun ou sur le grand âge et à
la place toujours plus de 49,3
épuisement républicain enfin avec votre
obsession à délivrer des brevets et
arabourguir l'arc républicain alors la
seule question qui vaille pour vous
Madame bien plus que pour vous mais pour
les Français y a-t-il une vie heureuse
après les 100 jours merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés Messieurs les Députés Jérôme
Guedj j'ai envie de dire cher Jérôme
et oui parce que
il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui il me revient de d'avoir
de la mémoire pour nous de
il me revient de me souvenir des temps
malheureux vous étions assis sur ce banc
derrière qui est en moi après moi cette
courte du chômage qui n'en finissait pas
de ne pas s'inverser
monsieur le député au bout des 100 jours
le plein emploi vous dites qu'elle
progrès pour les Français plus de
mobilité professionnelle plus de pouvoir
d'achat du meilleur emploi le bon emploi
qui va avec le plein emploi monsieur le
député j'ai la mémoire pour nous deux
nous étions sur ces bancs au nouveau des
budgets de 2 ou 3 milliards pour la
rénovation thermique la première
ministre vient d'annoncer ce dimanche 7
milliards supplémentaires qui s'ajoutent
au 25 milliards déjà engagés dans le cas
de la planification écologique vous et
moi aurions je le dis je le dis et vous
en souvenez parce qu'au fond vous avez
de la mémoire nous aurions salué ce type
d'annonce en disant que ça allait dans
le bon sens que vous est-il arrivé
monsieur le député pour ne plus pouvoir
le reconnaître est-ce que c'est la
nupcation qui vous a rendu aveugle au
progrès pour les Français je me pose la
question vous parlez de l'hôpital
monsieur le député nous étions dans la
même commission le budget annuel accordé
à l'hôpital était de 18 milliards de
moins que ce qu'il est aujourd'hui avec
Emmanuel Macron reconnaissait les
progrès le dédoublement des classes
bientôt l'extension des horaires de
cours vous y étiez favorable je me
souviens une solution que nous avions
l'un et l'autre sur ces sujets que vous
est-il arrivé monsieur le député-gage
ouvrez les yeux rejoignez rejoignez
cette majorité il n'est jamais trop tard
nous portons des progrès pour les
Français vous auriez tout intérêt à vous
en rendre compte
quand vous regardez sur votre gauche ce
qu'il y a à voir ne fait pas au vieux
français je suis sûr que vous n'êtes pas
obligé
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est matin et à Madame Emilie
Chandeleur pour le groupe Renaissance
ma question ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le ministre depuis
le 27 juin notre pays a connu des nuits
de troubles et d'affrontements des nuits
durant lesquelles nous avons été
nombreux sur les bancs de cette
hémicycle a appelé au calme appelé au
respect de la loi de la République
durant ces nuits les policiers les
gendarmes et les sapeurs-pompiers
l'ensemble des services de l'État se
sont mobilisés et ont répondu avec le
plus grand professionnelisme un
dévouement exemplaire à des situations
tendues et violentes je tiens à saluer
leur engagement et leur travail ils ont
fait leurs devoirs protéger les Français
808 policiers gendarmes ainsi que 35
sapeurs-pompiers ont été blessés durant
les heures autant de blessures qui
marqueront nos forces de l'ordre et de
secours aussi sûrement que les images de
violence dont nous avons été témoins et
qui ont marqué notre pays
pourtant au sein de notre hémicycle
certains députés font peu de cas du
travail immense pour ramener le calme
dans nos rues ces élus soufflent les
braises en participant à des
manifestations interdites par les
services de l'État en écharpe tricolore
quand certains chantent tout le monde
détestent la police lorsque le préfet du
Val-d'Oise mont département a décidé de
s'opposer à la tenue d'une marche en
mémoire d'Adama Traoré à
Beaumont-sur-Oise et à Persan qu'une
autre organisée à Paris a-t-elle aussi
été interdite ils ont considéré qu'il
participait n'était pas illégal un
comble pour des élus dont la fonction
est de construire la loi à croire que
nos collègues cherchent à assumer aucune
responsabilité il cherche à faire monter
l'attention à soutenir la violence c'est
oublier que la mairie de Persan a été
incendiée son centre communal d'action
sociale et son poste de police
municipale saccagé c'est une commune
meurtrie qui ont besoin de penser ses
plaies pas de nouvelles échauffourées
la vérité monsieur le ministre c'est que
des mouvements d'ultra gauche
instrumentisent l'émotion légitime que
nous avons tous ressentis ma question
est donc simple monsieur le ministre
comment le gouvernement compte-t-il
concrétiser la reconnaissance et le
soutien à apporter à nos forces de
l'ordre je vous remette merci beaucoup
ma chère collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
je crois que les Français dans leur
ensemble ont été extrêmement choqués que
des parlementaires en écharpe puissent
défiler au son de tout le monde déteste
la police
et je veux dire que ceux qui ont défilé
au son de tout le monde déteste la
police sans s'écarter
sans faire un tweet sans regretter ne
déshonore pas la police nationale mais
déshonore leurs mandat et la vie de
femmes et d'hommes politiques
alors madame la députée plutôt que
donner publicité à des extrémistes qui
crachent sur la tombe des policiers
morts je voudrais ici depuis trois ans
vous lire et j'espère vous faire
applaudir dans l'ensemble cette émission
tous les policiers morts en service et
qui laissent des veufs des veuves des
orphelins
Frank laboie
Éric Mauroy
Freddy Allard
romain boulange
Vincent Martinez
Stéphane Le Meur
Amaury Lacroix de croûte
Stéphanie m'ont fermé
Eric Masson
Wilfried Faro
Steven keblack
Manon
Paul Medeiros
vive la république et vive la police
nationale
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence la
parole est à Madame Marianne Maximy pour
la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la première même
ministre mais avant ça monsieur Darmanin
quel instrumentalisation et qu'à le
honte vous devenez nous faire
vous affirmez que nous serions sortis de
l'arc républicain
madame la Première ministre
que reste-t-il de l'arc républicain dès
les législatives vous l'avez détruit
quand vous avez appelé à faire barrage
contre nous face au rassemblement
national
pourtant au second tour de la
présidentielle vous avez pu compter sur
les électeurs de gauche qui ont voté
POUR VOUS contre l'extrême droite ce
jour-là ils étaient républicains que
s'est-il passé la réponse est simple la
nupesse a mis votre partie en minorité
elle vous inquiète plus que 89 députés
du rassemblement national car nous
représentons une alternative crédible à
votre politique une rupture face au
libéralisme autoritaire le rassemblement
national est une arnaque sociale il ne
constestera jamais vos mesures
néolibérales leur vote en sont la preuve
tout est bon pour fracturer la nups même
rogner des décennies de lutte contre
l'extrême droite collègue je vous pose
la question est-ce un petit républicain
de vouloir une police sans racisme alors
dans ce cas là l'ONU est anti
républicaine
vous donnez des leçons mais qui menacent
de couper les subventions de l'aldah qui
détournent le fond Marianne qui écrase
le Parlement qui se tait quand les
syndicats de police menacent les
sédition que répondez-vous au festival
de propos racistes des républicains dans
les médias rien attaquer les
contre-pouvoirs interdire des
manifestations pacifistes fracturer la
société c'est ça abîmer la République à
force de courir derrière l'extrême
droite vous allez tomber et le plus dur
ce n'est pas la chute mais
l'atterrissage la République ce n'est
pas un outil de domination ce n'est pas
une carte qu'on a à battre contre ces
oppositions la République c'est la
souveraineté du peuple la République
c'est celles et ceux qui veulent la
liberté l'égalité et la fraternité merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement et ministre
en charge de renouveau démocratique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame les députés
Maximy
vous posez cette question
vous posez cette question pour vous
faire passer pour des victimes
et vous cherchez à vous faire passer
pour des victimes parce que vous vous
rendez compte que vous n'avez pas été à
la hauteur de la situation
en disant que la police tue en parlant
d'une loi comme d'un permis de tuer en
affirmant que certains bâtiments ne sont
pas à détruire mais peut-être en
excluant éventuellement d'autres
bâtiments en participant avec l'écharpe
tricolore républicaine autour du cou a
des manifestations interdites par les
préfets de la République vous vous
rendez compte madame la députée que vous
n'avez pas été à la hauteur et certains
de vos partenaires sont là à nos côtés
pour vous le dire
c'est trop facile madame la députée la
ficelle est un peu éculée les Français
ne vous croient plus si vous voulez
rentrer dans le champ républicain madame
la députée respectez la République
respectez votre mandat et short que vous
portez et respecter les Français
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Philippe Gosselin
pour le groupe les républicain merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale quel
ministre êtes-vous donc dans des
dizaines de villes et même dans des
villes moyennes à leur épargné par les
émeutes et les violences urbaines on a
pillé et on a incendié plus de 2500
bâtiments publics ont été touchés plus
de 1000 commerces des mairies plus de
250 établissements d'enseignements et on
ne vous a pas entendu monsieur le
ministre des universitaires des
intellectuels des étudiants même des
monstres l'entrisme l'idéologie walk et
le la culture cancel qui se développe et
on ne vous entend toujours pas monsieur
le ministre vous demandez des efforts de
mixité sociale aux établissements
scolaires privés et vous avez sans doute
raison mais vous mettez vous même vos
enfants à l'École alsacienne temple de
l'entre-soi on ne vous entend pas bien
monsieur le ministre le niveau de nos
élèves recule les fondamentaux sont en
souffrance mais vous ne faites toujours
rien bien et aucun de nos concitoyens
n'a vraiment entendu ce que vous
souhaitiez faire on vous entend très mal
monsieur le ministre en revanche en
revanche vous démontrez tous vos talents
d'idéologues vous vous placez en arbitre
des élégances de la pensée d'ailleurs
évidemment souvent unique distribué bons
et mauvais points jeter les annathèmes
contre certains médias vous méprisez ce
faisant les journalistes et des équipes
qui travaillent et des millions et des
millions de nos concitoyens qui les
regardent et les écoutent bien sûr
j'évoque ici la polémique de ce week-end
avec cnews et Europe 1 là Monsieur le
Ministre on vous entend vraiment trop
alors plutôt que de vous immiscer dans
le fonctionnement des médias quand
allez-vous vraiment prendre la mesure de
vos fonctions de votre tâche pour notre
éducation nationale notre jeunesse quid
des abeilles de la laïcité du
harcèlement scolaire là Monsieur le
Ministre on voudrait vraiment vous
entendre merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est un monsieur
popenzahi ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Gosselin
je vous dirai un mot à propos des
questions scolaires je suis d'ailleurs
auditionné à cet égard dans quelques
heures si vous avez un quelconque
intérêt pour ces questions apparemment
pas vous assisterez à l'audition je vais
vous répondre je vais vous répondre sur
la deuxième partie de votre propos vous
faites partie d'un groupe qui a une
tradition républicaine égoïste qui a
longtemps combattu l'extrême droite et
je m'étonne donc que vous vous étonniez
des constats somme toute banale que je
fais sur l'évolution
d'une chaîne de télévision il y a la
liberté de la presse monsieur le député
il y a aussi la liberté d'expression ce
sont deux fondamentaux de la démocratie
il ne s'agit de censurer ni l'une ni
l'autre ma collègue Rima abdull Malak
déjà rappelé ici les obligations qui
s'imposent aux chaînes à travers la loi
de 1986 et vous le savez l'arcom a mis
en garde et mis en demeure plus d'une
vingtaine de fois la chaîne de
télévision que vous mentionnez je ne
suis pas le seul à faire ce constat
ai-je invité à boycotter age pointé du
doigt tel journaliste non je n'ai fait
que commenter de manière banale la ligne
politique d'une chaîne de télévision ce
qui est mon droit le plus strict
monsieur le député et je tiens à ce
droit comme vous avez le droit de
commenter ce que j'ai pu dire lors d'une
interview
merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre monsieur Gosselin
un petit lance s'il vous plaît
oui monsieur le ministre on attend un
ministre pleinement concentré sur ses
fonctions gouvernementales de ministre
de l'éducation nationale pas de censeurs
et pas de philosophe de base étage
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
permettez-moi simplement de vous
répondre par cette citation du président
Jacques Chirac en 2007 qui me semble
être d'actualité au combien ne composez
jamais avec l'extrémisme le racisme
l'antisémitisme le rejet de l'autre tout
dans l'âme de la France dit non à
l'extrémisme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame
Isabelle roche du groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre chargé
de la transition numérique on brûle tout
dans le 57 appelle à la guérilla en
Moselle interpellé à quelques kilomètres
de chez moi ce jeune homme de 16 ans
s'exprimait ainsi sur les réseaux
sociaux il faisait sa révolution seule
dans sa chambre tandis que d'autres
passaient aux actes sur la plupart des
plateformes dès que l'on regarde une
vidéo la viralité finitère s'organise
pour nous proposer des contenus
similaires ainsi pour certains pendant
plusieurs soirs c'est toute la France
qui s'embrasait dans d'autres bulles
d'informationnelles on attisé les
désordres et les conflits on appelait à
la haine et à la vengeance vous l'avez
dit Monsieur le Ministre les dynamiques
de viralité ont pu nourrir les
dynamiques et meetières au Sénat Michael
Valley et Claude malure ont récemment
révélé les conclusions de leur mission
d'enquête sur Tik Tok opacité sur
l'algorithme sur la gouvernance sur les
liens avec une puissance étrangère les
réseaux sociaux jouent un effet
multiplicateur à la fois des actes et de
leurs effets
au-delà de leur responsabilité c'est
leur fonctionnement qui nous faut
finement comprendre et expliquer si la
coopération avec les géants du numérique
dans cet épisode a été présenté comme
exemplaire ce sont seulement plusieurs
centaines de retraits médias de contenu
illicites qui ont été opérés une
approche indispensable mais pas
suffisante aussi à l'heure où nous nous
apprêtons à légiférer sur l'espace
numérique à l'aube de l'entrée en
service du DSA du DMA européen c'est sur
la connaissance et la compétence de nos
concitoyens et concitoyens sur le
fonctionnement des outils numériques que
je souhaite vous questionner nous avons
grâce à l'initiative du président Marc
Angeli prix nos responsabilités sur la
majorité numérique en complément et à la
lumière des événements récents il est
indispensable d'agir sur trois fronts la
régulation situation d'urgence la
responsabilité parentale numérique et la
pédagogie de l'usage des réseaux et du
numérique en général monsieur le
ministre nous sommes nombreux à partager
la nécessité d'agir je souhaite
connaître le chemin que vous comptez
emprunter je vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Noël barreau
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente merci pour votre question
quelques heures après le début des
émeutes à la demande du Président de la
République et de la première ministre
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur nous
avons convoqué les principales
plateformes de réseaux sociaux pour les
rappeler d'abord alors obligation devant
la loi le retrait des contenus illicite
qui leur sont signalés et la réponse
prompte aux réquisition qui leur sont
adressées par l'autorité administrative
et judiciaire nous leur avons demandé
par ailleurs d'exercer la plus grande
vigilance sur les fonctionnalités de
leurs services susceptibles de porter
atteinte à la sécurité et à l'ordre
public le résultat c'est que ce sont des
milliers de contenus qui ont été retirés
des centaines de comptes qui ont été
supprimés des dizaines de réquisitions
qui ont été traitées le résultat madame
la présente c'est que dans l'heure en
Ille-et-Vilaine dans le Pas-de-Calais en
Haute-Savoie en Pyrénées-Atlantiques
dans les Hauts-de-Seine et dans le
Val-de-Marne des individus ont été
condamnés à des peines de prison pour
s'être livré sur internet à des appels
au meurtre le policiers de gendarmes aux
menaces à des mers ou
aux menaces vis-à-vis de commissariat de
gendarmerie ou de bâtiments publics ceci
étant dit les obligations vous l'avez
rappelé vont se durcir pour les
plateformes de réseaux sociaux avec
l'entrée en vigueur le 25 août prochain
du Règlement sur les services numériques
obtenus l'année dernière par la France
de Outlook qui leur imposera de prendre
toutes les mesures pour éviter que leur
service porte atteinte à la sécurité
publique sous peine de lourdes sanctions
par ailleurs pour les auteurs avec le
projet de loi en cours de discussion
adopter la semaine dernière au Sénat
celles et ceux qui se livrent en ligne à
des faits de violence pour être
condamnés à une peine de bannissement
des réseaux sociaux s'agissant des
parents vous les rappeler la proposition
de loi qui est devenue loi de Laurent
Marc Angelli permettra d'activer la
responsabilité parentale et enfin pour
tirer tout le bilan de les des
événements tragiques que nous avons
connus j'ai constitué un groupe de
travail transpartisans à parité député
sénateur qui se réunira dès demain pour
tirer les leçons de l'épisode que nous
avons vécu
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à madame Béatrice Descamps
pour le groupe pilote merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur madame la ministre les
résultats du baccalauréat ont été
publiés la phase d'attribution des veaux
sur parcoursup se termine de nombreuses
étudiants ont retenté une candidature
sur parcoursup faute d'avoir obtenu
l'école de leur choix les années
précédentes or il semblerait que les
algorithmes de la plateforme parcoursup
face barrage au fil des années à ses
étudiants pourtant studieux et motivés à
titre d'exemple une jeune étudiante de
ma circonscription rêve de devenir
orthoptiste malgré de très bons
résultats et sans réelle explication sa
candidature à l'issue de l'obtention du
bac en 2020 ne lui avait pas permis
d'intégrer l'école d'orthoptiste loin de
se décourager elle avait intégré une
prépa à l'issue de laquelle elle a
malheureusement été encore bien classé
sur parcoursup mais bien plus loin que
l'année précédente donc elle rentre en
BTS après ce BTS qu'elle a terminé
brillamment cette année elle a reformulé
sa demande pour intégrer la formation
d'orthoptiste et se retrouve à nouveau
sur liste d'attente avec semble-t-il que
très peu de chance d'intégrer cette
formation l'année prochaine cette
situation pose clairement question
comment un élève peut essuyer autant de
refus alors même que son profil gagne en
compétence chaque année
madame la ministre je sais que vous avez
œuvré pour une amélioration progressive
et une meilleure transparence de la
plateforme dans quelle mesure parcoursup
donne-t-il réellement sa chance au choix
professionnel
niori t'il pas dans l'algorithme de
parcoursup une difficulté particulière
qui entraverait les chances de réussite
de certains élèves et étudiants selon
les écoles que puis-je répondre à ces
étudiants qui m'ont interpellé
je vous remercie ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame Sylvie Retailleau
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Béatrice Descamps d'abord merci pour
votre question précise qui permet
effectivement d'avoir des cas je
voudrais rappeler effectivement que la
phase d'admission parcoursup est
terminée le 7 juste pour vous donner un
chiffre à la fin de cette phase
d'admission principale c'est neuf
lycéens sur 10 au niveau des lycéens et
8 plus de 8 élèves en réorientation donc
le cas dont vous présentez sur 10 j'ai
regardé c'est 1,8 points de plus que
l'année dernière car effectivement il
faut avoir un oeil particulier à ses
étudiants en réorientation je pourrais
vous répondre non et nous avons vérifié
il n'y a rien qui bloque au niveau de la
plateforme c'est au niveau des
commissions d'enseignement que les
dossiers sont regardés étudiés et rien
ne bloque particulièrement au niveau des
étudiants en réorientation ceci dit
aujourd'hui les équipes de parcoursup
les rectorats restent mobilisés pour
cette phase cette deuxième phase
complémentaire il reste 100000 places
aujourd'hui sur 6300 formations et tous
les étudiants qu'ils soient lycéens ou
étudiants en réorientation sont
normalement contactés par téléphone ou
contact pour regarder leurs projets ce
que je peux leur conseiller aujourd'hui
c'est d'aller
se mettre sur les commissions d'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur au niveau des
rectorats de regarder précisément leur
dossier et au niveau des parcours
parcoursup aujourd'hui et reconnu au
niveau vous l'avez dit nous avons
progressé sur la transparence nous avons
aussi progressé sur les temps de stress
puisque la phase d'admission principale
a duré 37 jours cette année contre 108
en 2008 parce qu'effectivement élève et
parents nous ont demandé de réduire
cette période d'attente et de stress ce
que nous avons fait et nous continuerons
à accompagner et améliorer et en
particulier pour ces étudiants en
réorientation qu'il contact CKS et nous
regarderons particulièrement ces cas je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas porte
pour le groupe la France insoumise
monsieur Darmanin
samedi à l'appel du comité vérité et
justice pour Adama des centaines de
personnes ont défilé à Paris une marche
pacifique digne qui fait honneur à la
République antiraciste et à la
démocratie cette marche vous avez tenté
de l'empêcher en macronie en interdit
donc les marches antiracistes et on
laisse défiler des nazis votre arc
républicain n'est rien d'autre qu'un arc
réactionnaire nous serons toujours aux
côtés de celles et ceux qui se
mobilisent contre les violences
policières et pour la République
c'est violence vous l'aignez pourtant
Monsieur le Ministre elles existent et
elle se multiplient elles ont des noms
et des visages Cédric chouvia Adama
Traoré Ryana
ibrahimba aliusen Camara Naël et tant
d'autres ce sont les morts de vos
violences
depuis des mois la brave la terreur dans
les rues du pays en avril dernier déjà
000 citoyens avaient demandé leur
dissolution vous avez enterré la
pétition avec la complicité de l'extrême
droite ici en face
la réactionnaire est au service des
violences policières samedi la brave a
montré son nouveau visage une brigade
violente hors de contrôle anti
républicaine une brigade monsieur le
ministre qui a cassé le dispositif
d'évacuation de la manifestation mis en
place par leur propre collègue
monsieur Darmanin trouvez-vous normal
que des journalistes soient frappés et
jetés au sol monsieur Darmanin
trouvez-nous normal qu'un CRS et du
s'interposer pour protéger les
manifestants de la brave monsieur
Darmanin
nous savons nous savons monsieur
Darmanin que la préfecture n'a pas donné
les ordres à la brave intervenir nous
vous posons la question qui a donné
l'ordre à la brave d'être là à la fin de
la manifestation
merci la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés monsieur le député
Thomas porte vous auriez peut-être dû
commencer par le commencement la
manifestation déclarait à Persan a été
interdite par un préfet de la République
et validé par la justice administrative
vous avez souhaité quand je dis vous
c'est les organisateurs mais vous les
avez largement soutenus chacun en
convient organisé une contre
manifestation place de la République le
préfet de police a pris une nouvelle
interdiction de manifester et vous
n'avez pas contesté cette interdiction
monsieur le député trouvez-vous normal
que des parlementaires élus par la
nation
brave des décisions préfectorales
passent encore mais brave des décisions
de justice trouvez-vous normal d'être
parmi le full qui crient tout le monde
déteste la police
trouvez-vous normal
que l'on s’apprenne physiquement aux
forces de l'ordre et c'est sur cette
base là que les personnes notamment le
frère de Madame Traoré ont été
interpellés vous seriez amélioré
républicain si vous souteniez l'ordre
l'État de droit et les gens qui
aujourd'hui le défendent et risque tous
les jours leur vie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur porte
monsieur le ministre aucune réponse vous
n'êtes pas le ministre de l'Intérieur
vous êtes le ministre des violences
policières soumis à la brave nous
demandons la dissolution
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel
Pellerin pour le groupe Renaissance à
Monsieur le Ministre excusez-moi
monsieur le député
tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant mais je vous
je vous réitère non mais vous pouvez
vous
pouvez parler plus fort en empêche pas
que vous dites des contre-vérités je
vous encourage monsieur député comme l'a
fait le sénateur Jérôme Durin qui fait
lui aussi partie de la nupes devenir
passé quelques jours que dis-je quelques
heures avec des policiers soyez parmi
eux touchez leur salaire risquez votre
vie embrasser une dernière fois vos
enfants et alors vous pourrez faire les
gestes d'événement il est facile de
parler dans un fauteuil rouge il est
plus compliqué d'aller voir les
policiers bien en face
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Emmanuel Pellerin pour le
groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse Olivier Klein mini chargé de
la ville et du Logement monsieur le
ministre ils en veulent aux institutions
à tout le monde ces mots sont ceux d'un
médiateur social de Boulogne-Billancourt
ma circonscription qui n'a pas été
épargné par les émeutes
engagés dans d'autres villes comme
Meudon-la-Forêt ou le commissariat était
incendié les forces de police de
Boulogne-Billancourt étaient en
sous-effectif pour autant ma
circonscription ne s'est pas embrasée
grâce à 5 médiateurs référents et près
de 90 agents municipaux déployés pour
les circonstances par le maire dont je
salue ici le courage
si elles ont mis en exergue des
violences et des tensions sociales aigus
ces émeutes ont aussi eu pour avantage
de mettre en lumière le rôle fondamental
joué par les médiateurs sociaux
mise en place par le maire de
Boulogne-Billancourt Pierre Christophe
Baguet c'est médiateur assurent au
quotidien la tranquillité publique et
l'apaisement des situations les plus
conflictuelles ces agents prêt implantés
et sectorisés ont comme dénominateur
commun d'être issus des quartiers en
cause et de représenter une figure
d'autorité ils ont permis d'apaiser les
tensions de circonscrire des incendies
et d'éviter des pillages
je salue d'ailleurs mon collègue Patrice
Patrick Vignal qui a déposé une
proposition de loi visant à reconnaître
les médiateurs pour ce qu'ils sont de
vrais professionnels de la relation
reconstructeur d'un lien social disparu
dans les quartiers prioritaires ils
reconnecte les jeunes aux institutions
sociales face à ce constat monsieur le
ministre comment le gouvernement compte
il agir afin d'encourager les villes à
soutenir l'intervention des médiateurs
sociaux et à favoriser de vrais circuits
courts et transparents entre l'éducation
la justice la police et les
collectivités merci infiniment merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Emmanuel Pellerin je veux vous remercier
très chaleureusement de votre question
qui nous permet de mettre en lumière le
travail très important mené au quotidien
par les adultes en général par les
militants associatifs et par les
médiateurs dans les villes en général et
dans les quartiers populaires en
particulier ça me permet de d'adresser
de leur adresser toute notre
reconnaissance aux médiateur médiateurs
municipaux auprès de 5000 adultes relais
au 600 personnes qui travaillent dans
les médiations de la prévention chère à
Nadia et qui joue un rôle très important
dans nos quartiers et qui ont joué un
rôle très important dans l'objectif qui
était le nôtre celui du retour au calme
du retour à l'ordre dans nos quartiers
populaires aux côtés des forces de
police bien sûr aux côtés des élus aux
côtés des adultes parce que dans un
moment comme celui-là c'est vraiment le
moment le temps des adultes et
l'ensemble de ceux qui ont contribué ont
joué un rôle important
comme vous je crois au rôle fondamental
de ce métier si important dans la
politique de la ville celui des
médiateurs et je salue aussi la
réflexion menée par le député Patrick
Vignal sur ce métier ce Mercier qui joue
un rôle très important dans différents
domaines celui de celui de l'école les
médiateurs scolaires jouent un rôle
important celui de l'accès aux soins
celui de la lutte contre le décrochage
et la fracture numérique beaucoup de
médiateurs ont été mis en place par le
précédent gouvernement et joue un rôle
très important le gouvernement est le
premier la première ministre l'a dit le
président de la République l'ont dit
aussi ce métier de médiation doit être
reconnu doit être faire l'objet d'un
travail en profondeur de reconnaissance
de formation et aussi de simplification
notamment dans le recrutement des
adultes relais et nous y travaillons
dans le cadre de quartier 2030 pour que
ces métiers jouent un rôle toujours plus
important aux côtés des associations qui
sont vous le savez l'alpha et l'oméga de
la réussite de la politique de la ville
dans nos quartiers populaires je vous
remercie merci
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas sangsue
pour le groupe GDR merci merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
un an après la commission d'enquête
sanatoriale du groupe communiste et
l'excellent travail des sénateurs
assassis et basins la Cour des comptes
vient de vous rappeler à l'ordre sur le
recours excessif et coûteux au cabinet
de conseils privés dans la conduite des
politiques publiques de l'État depuis
2017 le coût des dépenses de conseil or
informatique a été multipliée par 3 et
demi pour atteindre 232 millions d'euros
cette dérive sur fond de copinage ce
matérialise par de nombreuses scandales
le recours à McKinsey pendant la crise
sanitaire leur étude fantoche sur
l'avenir du métier de professeur ou bien
le flou autour du devenir des
concessions autoroutières laissées à des
conseillers privés depuis 8 mois une
proposition de loi sénatoriale adoptée
sans aucun vote contre et déposer sur le
bureau de notre assemblée renforcer la
transparence encadrer le recours aux
prestations de conseil prévenir
pas une fois de plus que Parlement et
par la même la République
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Stanislas Guérini
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Nicolas sangsue vous avez mentionné à
votre question le rapport récent de la
Cour des comptes les travaux que vous
avez menés avec Marie le bec qui faisait
suite à la commission d'enquête
parlementaire sénatorial je vais d'abord
dire ici qu'il est sain et utile dans
une démocratie que le tel travaux puisse
se conduire c'est ça utile parce que ça
permet d'établir la réalité des faits
alors la réalité des faits quelle
est-elle la réalité des faits c'est que
toutes les recommandations qui met la
Cour des comptes toutes les
recommandations c'est précisément ce que
le bonheur gouvernement met en oeuvre
depuis deux ans point par point alors
soyons factuels janvier 2022 circulaire
du Premier ministre pour établir une
doctrine d'encadrement des prestations
de conseils et fixer un cap la réduction
de 15% des dépenses de recours aux
prestations externes fin 2022 nouvelle
accord cadre interministériel qui
encadre l'intégralité
recours aux dépenses de conseils il a
été publié officiellement il intègre la
quasi-totalité des recommandations
sénatoriales
encadrement des montants interdiction
des droits de suite destruction
systématique des données chez les
cabinets de conseils et intégration chez
les administrations interdiction des
démarches alors voilà quand on vous
évoque les faits ça vous intéresse un
petit peu moins fin 2022 fin 2022
publication d'un jaune budgétaire
c'est-à-dire d'une annexe qui est
maintenant inscrite qui est maintenant
inscrite au PLF à disposition de tous
les parlementaires et de tous les
Français elle recense point par point
toutes les prestations de conseils des
cabinets ministériels et les résultats
sont là Monsieur le Député ça vous
intéressera parce que je sais que vous
faites partie de ceux qui veulent nous
aider et bien là où nous étions fixés
moins 15% de recours aux prestations de
conseils et bien je vous donne les
résultats pour l'année 2022 c'est moins
35%. alors les faits sont têtus monsieur
le député ils sont là et c'est le fruit
de l'action de ce gouvernement
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est un monsieur Nicolas
Thierry pour le groupe écologiste merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé vous
avez probablement pris connaissance du
pré rapport de l'AFSA relatif au
glyphosate publié le 6 juillet c'est une
question de santé publique majeure en
2017 Emmanuel Macron c'était engagé pour
une interdiction nuglyphosate voilà ce
que le président de la République disait
le glyphosate il n'y a aucun rapport qui
dit que c'est innocent il y en a qui
disent que c'est très dangereux d'autres
que c'est moyennement dangereux et
d'ajouter demain les ouvriers agricoles
les consommateurs me diront vous le
saviez vous n'avez rien fait et il me
regarderont les yeux dans les yeux
quand Emmanuel Macron disait cela il
portait la voix des scientifiques
français en effet l'Inserm notre
prestigieux institut scientifique
confirme une nouvelle fois en 2021 je
les cite que de nombreuses études
mettent en évidence des dommages
génotoxiques c'est-à-dire des cassures
de l'ADN du côté du Centre international
de recherche sur le cancer basé à Lyon
et en lien étroit avait la recherche
française même conclusion les preuves de
la génotoxicité du glyphosate sont
fortes autre contribution émanant aussi
du brillant institut français l'inrae sa
conclusion est sans appel en 2022
l'Institut montre encore une fois
l'impact du glyphosate sur la fertilité
animale et humaine étonnamment suite à
ces constats scientifiques formels lève
ça déduit pour reprendre la terminologie
de l'agence que le glyphosate ne
présente pas de domaine critique de
préoccupation
la différence fondamentale entre lève ça
agence réglementaire et les instituts de
recherche et le choix déterminant des
données lève ça s'appuie prioritairement
sur les études fournies par les firmes
agrochimiques les instituts de recherche
sur la littérature scientifique sans
surprise leur conclusion sont
différentes monsieur le ministre votre
confiance se porte et je ne peux
imaginer le contraire sur les
compétences et scientifiques français et
sur notre système de recherche ma
question est donc simple confirmez-vous
la promesse du président de sortir du
glyphosate et sachant que les instituts
de recherche ont unanimes pouvez-vous
nous dire quand cet engagement sera
effectif merci pour votre réponse je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Marc phénom au
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Thierry permettent témoin de vous
répondre en trois points le premier
point c'est vous avez raison faut se
baser sur la science mais moi je ne trie
pas la science et pardon de vous dire
que les données sur lequel se base lève
ça c'est les mêmes données que sur
lesquelles se basent loin de cesse et
leur c'est pas parce que le thermomètre
vous plaît pas que vous devez casser le
thermomètre et donc si on rentre dans le
logique jamais vous ne m'avez entendu et
c'est assez savoureux de vous entendre
quand il y a quelques semaines vous me
vilipendiez parce que j'avais simplement
pas remis en cause les données de
l'ancien simplement poser la question de
la chronologie alors je vous invite à ne
pas rentrer dans une logique qui
consisterait à rentrer dans la remise en
cause des agences y compris des agences
européennes et de ne pas opposer les
agents européennes et les agences
françaises je pense que c'est une erreur
tragique deuxième élément il n'y a pas
ça qui a dit ça et aussi l'Agence
européenne des produits chimiques qui a
conclu à l'absence
de lien cancérogènes mutagène ou
toxiques à la reproduction c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est cette agence et s'élève
ça néanmoins quelle est la position va
porter la France puisque désormais il y
aura une position qui se rapportait le
15 décembre prochain la position qui va
porter la France c'est la position de
partout on peut trouver des alternatives
de sortir du glyphosate est-ce que nous
avons fait depuis 2017 et donc de faire
en sorte que partout il y a des
alternatives on puisse avancer sur le
sujet et nous avons des résultats
monsieur le député depuis 2017 c'est
-30% sur les usages - 27% sur les usages
depuis 2017 c'est moins 30% sur l'achat
du glyphosate et donc il y a pas besoin
d'attendre l'Europe pour avancer
simplement il y a une chose qu'il faut
trouver c'est de la cohérence la
cohérence c'est de chercher des
alternatives la cohérence c'est pouvoir
se dire quand il y a des impasses la
cohérence c'est de se mettre dans une
trajectoire de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires la cohérence ça peut pas
être le Yaka faucon et de défendre des
totems sinon on y arrivera pas et je
vous attends pour qu'on essaie d'y
arriver sur cette trajectoire qui est
une trajectoire exigeante mais
nécessaire
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député
je prends bonne note que sur une
question ne sentait publique majeur
c'est le ministre de l'Agriculture qui
répond
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien Lopez
ligori pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente c'est ma
question s'adresse aux garde des sceaux
monsieur le ministre le statut de député
de la nation ne nous place pas au-dessus
des lois au contraire il nous oblige
envers la France et les Français
pourtant des élus de la nups présents
dans cette émission nous ont offert une
fois encore un spectacle consternant ce
samedi en participant à une
manifestation interdite
ce pavanant sous les cris de tout le
monde déteste la police
fidèle à elle-même l'extrême gauche nous
prouve sa haine des forces de l'ordre et
à travers elle la haine de la France oui
j'accuse mesdames panneaux Rousseau
Simono Simonet kéké j'accuse monsieur
Boyard porte Coquerel le Gâvre léoman et
bilongo
j'accuse la France insoumise et les
écologistes de souffler sur les braises
de l'anarchie vous avez choisi votre
camp en affichant votre soutien au gang
Traoré une famille qui a son actif des
dizaines des dizaines de condamnations
pour violence aggravée cambriolage
trafic de stupéfiants et même viol votre
manie pathologique à vous entourer de
délinquance dangereux comme les traorés
de fanatic sans limites comme ceux du
soulèvement de la terre ou encore de
millise violente comme la jeune garde en
dit long sur le projet que vous portez
pour notre pays alors ce n'est pas
l'assemblée de sanctionner ces députés
c'est aux Français de les sanctionner
dans les urnes et c'est à la justice
d'agir car oui une manifestation
interdite est interdite pour tout le
monde même pour les députés ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est l'article r644 du
code pénal que certains seraient bien
avisés de relire monsieur le garde des
sceaux le message que vous ayez vous
aviez adressé au procureur
après les manifestations scandales
scandaleuses sensolyn était à raison
celui de la fermeté comptez-vous
appliquée ce même message de fermeté au
députés qui ont déshonoré leur fonction
en participant à ces manifestations
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Applaudissements]
à quelques jours de ses émeutes monsieur
le député
Aurélien Lopez zigori je trouve qu'il
est effectivement scandaleux de voir des
élus de la République saint de leur
écharpe tricolore
ne pas quitter les lieux lorsqu'on crie
on déteste la police
moi je ne déteste pas la police j'aime
la police j'aime la justice j'aime la
République
j'aime la Constitution de 1958
monsieur le député
le garde des sceaux n'a pas la
possibilité de donner des directives de
poursuites au parquet vous avez toujours
la possibilité d'adresser au procureur
de la République un article 40 car
effectivement participé à une
manifestation interdite est une
infraction
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Hardouin pour le groupe Renaissance
madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Jean-Noël Barrault
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
monsieur le ministre l'essor d'Internet
et des réseaux sociaux a été une
formidable opportunité pour la
transmission du savoir de l'information
et pour la libération de la parole mais
cette liberté à laquelle nous sommes
tous viscéralement attachés à une part
d'ombre qui tient dans le sentiment
d'impunité de certains internautes début
2019 et encore récemment le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron s'est dit
favorable à l'étude de la levée de
l'anonymat sur internet je partage cette
position courageuse qu'il nous revient
de concrétiser
[Applaudissements]
nous ne pouvons nous résoudre entendre
ces récits d'hommes et de femmes et bien
trop souvent de collégiens ou de lycéens
victimes de harcèlement de moquerie
d'humiliation gratuite sous couvert
d'anonymat certains de nos enfants vont
jusqu'à mettre fin à leur jour car là où
la chaleur des foyers protéger les
jeunes du harcèlement les réseaux
sociaux prolongent leur chemin de croix
jusque dans leur domicile familial cette
situation est insupportable et
inacceptable nous ne vont trouver le
juste équilibre entre liberté et vie
privée des internautes d'une part et la
sanction des personnes qui en abusent
d'autre part nous devons être plus
exigeants avec les opérateurs numériques
peu enclin à apporter leur concours aux
forces de police et à la justice nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que des opérateurs
protègent ceux qui parlent l'acheter et
n sous anonymat derrière un écran
détruisent la vie de nos concitoyens les
plus vulnérables en février 2022 nous
avons voté une loi pour lutter contre le
harcèlement scolaire c'est une étape
essentielle qui nous faut prolonger en
assurant plus amplement la protection
des en ligne monsieur le ministre
peut-on envisager la mise en place de
mesures d'identification plus
contraignantes sur les réseaux sociaux
afin de retrouver plus facilement les
auteurs de harcèlement d'injures et de
diffamation en ligne je vous remercie
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Noël Barrault
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
merci Madame les présidentes mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
Jean-Philippe Hardouin vous avez raison
le cyber-harcèlement est un fléau dont
tous les Français peuvent être victimes
à tous les âges de la vie et plus
particulièrement les femmes qui sont 27
fois plus souvent victimes de
cybercellement et bien évidemment les
enfants puisque dès le collège le
harcèlement se déplace de la cour
d'école jusque sur les réseaux sociaux
et sur les smartphones mais
permettez-moi de rappeler monsieur le
député qu'il n'y a pas d'anonymat sur
les réseaux sociaux que nul ne peut
impunément propager la haine sur
Internet même derrière un pseudo même
derrière avatar les agresseurs de Mila
les agresseurs du chanteur Eddy De
Pretto les agresseurs de la chanteuse
Hoshi ont toutes été
identifiées traduit devant la justice et
condamné à des peines de prison allant
jusqu'à un an d'emprisonnement et 5000
euros d'amende ceci étant dit vous avez
raison il nous faut accroître la
responsabilité de chacun pour faire
reculer le cyberharcèlement celle des
plateformes et ce sera le cas avec
l'entrée en vigueur du Règlement sur les
services numériques qui les astreindra à
prendre toutes les mesures de protection
de l'enfance sous peine de sanction
allant jusqu'à 6% du chiffre d'affaires
mondial voir au bannissement de l'Union
européenne en cas de manquement répété
ce sera le cas avec l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi de Bruno Studer ou de la loi
de Laurent Marc Angeli qui va activer la
responsabilité parentale ce sera la cas
avec la mise en oeuvre de la loi
Balanant et avec le projet de loi
numérique adopter la semaine dernière au
Sénat qui va permettre au juge de
prononcer une peine complémentaire de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux pendant
une période de six mois lorsqu'une
personne est reconnue coupable de fait
de cyber-harcèlement scolaires mais la
lutte contre le cyber-harcèlement
scolaire comme la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire suppose une
approche de bout en bout c'est la raison
pour laquelle madame la Première
ministre a convoqué vendredi
une réunion avec les membres de son
gouvernement pour préparer dès la
rentrée un plan d'action global qui vise
le harcèlement et qui visait en
particulier le cyber-harcèlement et les
questions que vous soulevez
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Juvin
pour le couple républicains
madame la Présidente cette question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé monsieur le ministre nous manquons
de médecins partout pourquoi parce que
nous n'en formons pas assez alors nous
vous l'avons dit mille fois et je vous
le redis encore aujourd'hui vous devez
doubler le numéro clausus alors en
attendant cette décision nous vous
faisons une proposition pour augmenter
dès maintenant le nombre de médecins en
France comme chaque année un concours va
être organisé pour permettre à des
médecins diplométrangers hors Union
Européenne d'exercer en France cette
année il y a 20 000 candidats c'est
formidable 20000 il y en a jamais eu
autant et pourtant décidément c'est une
manie de votre administration vous avez
fixé un humérus clausus sur ces 20 000
vous avez d'ores et déjà décidé qu'on en
prendrait 2700 pas plus même s'ils ont
de niveau mais ce ministre les Français
n'ont plus de médecins pourquoi n'en
prendre que 2700 2700 ça n'a aucun sens
prenait tous ceux qui ont le niveau
faites un examen pas un concours seconde
proposition
vos 2700 sont prêts affectés dans des
hôpitaux pour deux ans c'est très bien
ne changez rien et bien faites pareil
dans nos territoires dans nos communes
dans nos maisons de santé sur les 20.000
il y en a plus de 6500 qui sont
candidats en médecine générale si la
moitié avait le niveau et ça le l'examen
le dira ça ferait 30 ou 40 médecins
généralistes dans chacun de nos
départements c'est énorme pas dans 10
ans mais dans 6 mois au premier janvier
chez le ministre il y a des solutions au
désert médicaux mais il y a une
condition il faut changer de méthode il
faut arrêter avec toutes ces décisions
de numérus clausus qui sont prises à
Paris et qui sont absolument inadaptés
aux besoins de nos territoires on ne
peut pas à la fois se plaindre qu'on a
pas assez de médecins et continuer de
refuser à de bons médecins de travailler
et à des jeunes lycées à motiver de
faire médecine
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
député Philippe juvain merci de mettre
un peu le doigt sur cette problématique
de ces praticiens à diplôme en Union
Européenne ces fameux pas durs alors
concernant ces praticiens il
subissent où il bénéficie d'un parcours
déjà exigeant pour la reconnaissance de
leur diplôme vous l'avez dit il passe un
examen il passe ensuite devant des des
jurys différents en fonction des
spécialités qui peuvent valider tout de
suite leur spécialité ou au contraire
leur demander de faire des stages
complémentaires dans le cadre d'une
formation pour être au niveau concernant
l'ensemble de ces padus la ministre
délégué Agnès Firma le Bodo a conduit
déjà une sécurisation des 3800 médecins
la procédure stock qui était en attente
de validation pendant cette période
covid de leur diplôme ils ont été
validés ils sont maintenant sécurisés
dans nos établissements et effectivement
le concours des EVC permet tous les ans
d'apporter 2700 médecins supplémentaires
dans l'ensemble des spécialités alors
nous ne faisons rien ainsi et d'ailleurs
dans cette assemblée vous avez validé la
PPL de votre collègue Frédéric valtoux
qui va nous permettre d'accélérer ces
validations de faciliter ces
certifications et de former encore plus
de médecins et d'ailleurs nous avons
également validé dans cette émission la
possibilité d'ajouter à ces médecins la
notion de passeport Talence c'est-à-dire
aller chercher des professionnels
talentueux pour les faire venir encore
plus rapidement notre établissement il
est d'ailleurs surprenant de voir que
les députés du rassemblement national
pourtant très prompt à nous dire que
nous ne faisons rien avoir voulu
supprimer ces articles ils verront dans
leur territoire ruraux qu'elles en ont
sont les conséquences alors ces
professionnels sont essentiels vous avez
fait un petit lapsus en parlant de
numérus clausus pour la formation de
médecine il s'agit effectivement du
numerus à Perthus qui a vu
l'augmentation de 15% des étudiants et
cela continue à se produire on peut
considérer que c'est pas assez mais si
on veut garder la qualité pour former
des médecins il faut aussi des
enseignants je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre monsieur
le député
monsieur le ministre j'ai pas bien saisi
votre réponse mais moi je pense que si
vous ne doublez pas le numerus clausus
c'est que votre administration
administration refuse et bien si elle
refuse il faut changer votre
administration vous n'êtes pas là pour
appliquer la politique de votre
administration vous êtes là pour imposer
votre politique et votre administration
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Guy Bricout
pour le groupe yote merci merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin monsieur le ministre en
mars 2017 le plan préfecture nouvelle
génération était présenté aux Français
il visait à simplifier à accélérer et à
améliorer la délivrance des titres en
transférant au mairies volontaires le
renouvellement des passeports et des
cartes d'identité or nous sommes passés
de 12 jours pour obtenir un rendez-vous
en avril 2021 à plus de 65 jours en
moyenne depuis l'année 2022 selon le
rapport d'information sur la délivrance
des titres d'identité en date de mai
2023 dont Charles de Courson a été le
rapporteur celui-ci démontre que la
durée d'instruction de la demande s'est
accrue
elle est passée aujourd'hui de 20 jours
à au lieu de 15 et le délai ne cesse
d'augmenter depuis 2018
les passeports et les cartes d'identité
ne sont pas les seuls titres touchés
alors que la France est l'un des pays
les plus visités au monde si ce n'est le
premier les délais d'obtention des visas
pose un réel problème pour les étrangers
souhaitant venir en France à cet égard
avec mon groupe nous avons échangé avec
les députés sénégalais ces derniers nous
ont fait part de délai qu'il juge
anormaux en effet alors que le Sénégal
est un ami de la France il leur faut
environ six mois pour obtenir un visa ce
qui nuit à l'image de notre pays à
l'international en effet
de plus et par expérience personnelle le
contrôle effectué par la police aux
frontières dans les aéroports français
et lui aussi fastidieux en Chine il m'a
fallu moins d'un quart d'heure pour
faire tous les contrôles d'identité en
France au sein de mon propre pays il m'a
fallu quasiment deux heures lors de mon
retour monsieur le ministre afin de
répondre aux attentes des Français et
des touristes qu'en est-il des solutions
annoncées par le gouvernement en avril
2023 dans l'Indre et par ailleurs que
pendant ce gouvernement des mesures
envisagées par le rapport d'information
dont j'ai parlé chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Guy Bricout vous déposez finalement deux
formes de questions la première sur la
délivrance des titres d'identité par les
préfectures et sous-préfectures et les
mairies qui nous contribuent évidemment
beaucoup à ces titres d'identité vous
connaissez les raisons pour lesquelles
il y avait du retard l'appareil de covid
et le non renouvellement de ces pièces
d'identités la première ministre a
décidé un plan massif d'accélération de
librement de ces pièces d'identité la
ministre Dominique Ford dont je salue le
travail et l'engagement a permis
aujourd'hui de réduire dans votre
département monsieur député dans notre
département à moins de 30 jours
désormais pour avoir sa pièce d'identité
et je vais dire que partout en France
désormais il y a des places et des
créneaux disponibles pour renouveler
cette plaisanté et donc il y a plus de
problèmes pour les vacances de cet été
pour les visas que nous partageons
ministère de l'Intérieur et ministère
des Affaires étrangères vous le savez
bien dans les consulats les ambassades
il y a effectivement parfois du retard
pour plusieurs raisons que je voudrais
évoquer ici mais la première ministre
est le président de la République ont
commandé un un monsieur Hermelin rapport
qui nous a été rendu avec Catherine
Colonna nous allons en tirer toutes les
conséquences pour améliorer le process
qui permet aux étrangers de venir sur le
sol national en obtenant un visa mais
vous savez monsieur député vous avez
cité plusieurs pays a mis de la France
que nous avons aussi à faire face à une
immigration irrégulière qui prend
souvent la possibilité d'un visage
touristique ou d'un visa de travail pour
rester illégalement sur le territoire
national et donc nous devons davantage
améliorer nos process pour permettre
effectivement
c'est tout à fait normal pour la France
d'accueillir destination touristique
destination d'étudiants destination de
scientifiques ou de chercheurs tous ceux
qui veulent venir en France et puis en
même temps lutter contre cette émission
irrégulière des moyens supplémentaires
seront mis vous savez qu'il y a de
grandes transformations numériques pour
aider les postes de consulat qui ont des
grosses difficultés notamment dans les
pays Maghreb et l'Afrique et puis bien
évidemment un lien plus fort avec les
pays je me suis rendu moi-même au
Sénégal pour pouvoir avoir une politique
de visa bien connue des deux côtés bien
sûr j'aurais juste amener ma la
présidente pour signifier que la
comparaison de la Chine me paraît un peu
étonnante puisque là-bas ils ont la
reconnaissance faciale ce qui fait
facilite vous le conviendrez le contrôle
de police merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
François Gernigon pour le COP horizon
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Dupont-Moretti
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
l'autorité d'un professeur l'autorité
d'un officier de gendarmerie l'autorité
d'un juge l'autorité d'un éducateur et
même l'autorité d'un parent en fin de
compte l'autorité de l'État quand
reste-t-il aujourd'hui
ces figures autrefois respectées voient
désormais leur autorité constamment
remise en question
ce n'est pas acceptable nous ne serions
nous résoudre à accepter passivement ce
déclin
en tant qu’ancien maire je l'ai vu de
mes yeux des enfants livrés eux-mêmes
adoptaient de mauvais comportements sans
que les services sociaux ou judiciaires
ne soient en capacité de leur offrir des
solutions adaptées
les récentes émeutes dont nous avons été
les témoins en sont s'il le fallait une
preuve supplémentaire
un certain nombre de jeunes c'est en
livré à ses actes de délinquance ont été
dirigés vers des centres éducatifs
fermés
ces structures adaptées jouent un rôle
crucial et je tiens à saluer
l'engagement de l'ensemble des acteurs
éducateurs notamment qui chaque jour
tente de changer des trajectoires de vie
mais leur capacités sont naturellement
limitées malgré le programme de 20
créations de nouveaux centres annoncées
en 2018 il nous faut désormais aller
plus loin
ces centres doivent évoluer pour
accueillir davantage les jeunes qui sont
en décrochage dès la première
transgression ce que les parents
n'arrivent plus à contrôler avant qu'ils
ne se perdent dans une spirale de
délinquance toujours plus grave
comment pouvons-nous faire évoluer ses
centres pour les ouvrir un plus grand
nombre de jeunes
en définitive quelle action votre
ministère entend-t-il mené pour lutter
plus efficacement et plus durablement
contre les pertes de cadres et
d'autorité d'une partie de notre
jeunesse pour l'avenir de notre pays
mais avant tout pour l'avenir de chacun
des enfants de la République je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux et
ministre de la Justice
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député François gerligon je viens de
lire La Tribune que vous avez publiée
dans Le Courrier de l'Ouest et
permettez-moi de vous dire sans
flagornerie que j'en partage les termes
c'est vrai qu'une partie de notre
jeunesse fortement pas toutes notre
jeunesse mais une partie de notre
jeunesse est à la dérive et que cette
partie de notre jeunesse a besoin de
figure tutélaire en réalité par an
enseignant magistrats
policier et bien sûr que ce qui vient de
se dérouler nous oblige et je voudrais
vous apporter une réponse claire à ce
que nous avons fait d'abord la
responsabilité des parents
j'ai rappelé au procureur de la
République que c'était une infraction
que de mal s'occuper de ses enfants
quand on avait la capacité de faire bien
alors j'ai pris un flyer qui ne mérite
pas d'être moqué en réalité parce que
sur beaucoup de flyers on explique
toujours ce que sont les droits et
rarement ce que sont les devoirs et moi
j'ai souhaité rappeler à la fois qu'il y
avait une responsabilité pénale qu'elle
était double et une responsabilité
civile
s'agissant du judiciaire vous le savez
j'ai demandé une réponse rapide
systématique approprié et la justice je
le dis a été au rendez-vous de ces
obligations dans cette période si
difficile et c'est aussi grâce à la
justice que l'ordre républicain a été
rétabli s'agissant de l'éducation
nationale ça n'est pas mon périmètre
mais avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale nous avons mis en place un
parcours éduc droit qui est un mélange à
la fois de règles de droit mais
également monsieur le député de règle
civiques tout simplement ça s'applique à
tous les élèves des la troisième
partenariat armé justice je vais très
vite madame la Présidente et enfin les
chefs nous en avons 54 19 autres sont en
construction quatre vont ouvrir en 2024
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre
la parole est à Monsieur José Borin pour
le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
en charge de l'industrie en France
Monsieur le Ministre le 11 juin dernier
s'est déroulé au sein de la commune
axonnaise de Courmelles dans ma
circonscription une consultation
citoyenne à l'initiative du maire quant
au projet de construction d'une usine de
l'Industrielle danois recould
spécialiste dans la production de laine
de roche cette laine de roche est un
isolant important dans la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments cependant et
alors que recoudre s'est défendu a
raison des différentes externalités qui
aimaient certains produits utilisés pour
la fabrication de cette laine ces effets
continuent à inquiéter les habitants
ce suffrage qui avait pour question
êtes-vous pour ou contre l'implantation
de cette usine sur notre territoire a vu
le nom l'emporter après de 98%.
seulement le préfet de l'Aisne a décrété
a décidé que cette consultation
citoyenne était illégal et a décidé de
ne pas écouter la volonté populaire ce
n'est malheureusement pas une première
puisque le préfet de laine avait déjà
précédemment refusé d'entendre la voix
des habitants sur une consultation
précédente à l'initiative de 18 communes
qui s'opposaient à l'implantation d'un
parc éolien sur le sud du département
bien que nous ayons à faire un projet
industriel extrêmement intéressant et
nécessaire sur le plan économique et
social par la création de 150 emplois
directs son implantation géographique
post question une solution claire plus
précise plus adaptée aurait pu être
trouvé si une consultation préalable
avait été menée auprès des habitants
afin de trouver un emplacement plus
judicieux en conséquence monsieur le
ministre pour éviter les problèmes
démocratiques locaux de plus en plus
fréquents je vous le demande comment
allez-vous revaloriser pour chaque
projet d'implantation industrielle
susceptible d'avoir un impact sur
l'environnement des consultations
citoyennes préalables et qui aurait
une envergure démissionnelle définitive
et sanctuarisés je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre
chargé de l'industrie
[Applaudissements]
la présidente monsieur le député merci
pour votre question vous et votre groupe
vous aviez l'occasion la semaine
dernière de voter un très beau projet de
loin industriel verte qui permettait en
partie de répondre à votre question je
regrette que les parlementaires de votre
groupe qui étaient présents dans la
commission spéciale ne l'est pas votée
et j'en profite pour remercier toutes
celles et ceux qui ont soutenu ce projet
de loi qui vise à libérer du foncier
libéré du financement libérer des
installations simplifiées les procédures
je vais venir monsieur le député et
faire en sorte que les projets
industriels dans ton hôtel network
puisse créer de l'emploi créer de la
prospérité créer oui de l'acceptabilité
sociale puisque vous le savez sans doute
dans ce projet de loi nous augmentons la
durée de l'enquête publique nous nous
obligeons des rencontres publiques
officielles au moins deux au début à la
fin de manière à améliorer
l'acceptabilité de ces dossiers qui sont
souvent des dossiers importants pour
l'emploi vous l'avez dit pour les
territoires mais qui font parfois
l'objet de débat tendu c'est le cas du
projet auquel vous faites référence vous
le savez la plupart des élus étaient
derrière ce projet qui a fait l'objet
d'une enquête approfondie qui a fait
l'objet vous l'avez dit d'une
consultation qui elle n'était pas légale
on se retrouve aujourd'hui face à des
recours qu'il a encore vont être traités
dans le projet de loi industrielle donc
j'engage vraiment les membres de votre
groupe à le voter quand il sera en
hémicycle la semaine dernière la semaine
prochaine qui vont permettre
d'objectiver et de simplifier tout ça
l'industrialisation des territoires
c'est un défi énorme pour lequel
effectivement les industriels les
porteurs de projets les élus et le
public doivent être associés de manière
à s'assurer que tout le monde soit
derrière ses projets c'est visiblement
pas le cas pour ce projet je le regrette
des procédures judiciaires sont en cours
attendons de voir quel sort sera donné
au recours en attendant j'engage
vraiment tous les porteurs de projets à
s'assurer que l'ensemble des parties
prenantes soit consultés dans le cadre
de ces projets je le répète le projet
industrie verte permis de le faire merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
non il y a plus du tout le temps mon
cher collègue vous aviez déplacé déjà de
20 secondes
désolé
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
espionné gaugues pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre chargé de la
transition numérique le poids des mots
le choc des photos ce slogan longtemps
scandé par un célèbre journal français
pourrait être désormais celui de
certains réseaux sociaux car cette fois
ce sont les photos de pillages portées
en masse qui ont choqué nos concitoyens
tout comme les vidéos appelant au
rassemblement violent
en diffusant leurs délits les émeutiers
ont contribué à démultiplier la violence
et conduit aux destructions que nous
déplorons
pour amplifier l'action des plateformes
nous devons renforcer le responsabilité
de modération
toutefois comme vous avez pu déjà
l'affirmer ces responsabilités ne
doivent pas conduire à enfreindre la
liberté d'expression
l'héritage de la Révolution la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen édicte en son article 11 que la
livre communication des pensées et des
opinions est un des droits les plus
précieux de l'homme
certes Mirabeau s'is ou Lafayette
n'avait pas en tête que la liberté
s'exercerait en ligne mais nous devons
pourtant mesurer l'ampleur de notre vie
numérique les jeunes s'informent sur Tik
Tok les moins jeunes trouvent un emploi
sur LinkedIn et tous renforcent leurs
liens sur Facebook snapchat et Twitter
alors que certains appellent à cassé du
maire des commerces ou à la révolution
violente quelle sanctions peut-on leur
appliquer comment appeler les acteurs à
la responsabilité tout en s'assurant que
chaque réponse soit proportionnée et
individualisé de façon à garantir la
liberté d'expression comment faire en
sorte que ces plateformes se contentent
pas seulement de satisfaire à leurs
intérêts privés mais prennent bien en
compte l'intérêt général
la réponse est sans doute européenne car
c'est à cette échelle que l'action sera
plus forte et que pourra cesser enfin
l'effet démultiplicateur des réseaux
alors monsieur le ministre que peut
faire le gouvernement pour assurer un
espace numérique libre et apaisé je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Jean-Noël barreau ministre
délégué chargé de transitions numériques
et des télécommunications merci Madame
la présente mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député Laurent
est-ce que né la liberté d'expression
c'est la pierre d'angle de la France des
Lumières c'est le socle de notre
démocratie c'est un trésor qu'il nous
faut préserver et qu'il nous faut chérir
et les réseaux sociaux contribuent à la
liberté d'expression et à la liberté
d'information dans bien des pays pour
les peuples opprimés les réseaux sociaux
sont le moyen de résister de s'informer
de communiquer
et nos concitoyens utilisent
quotidiennement les réseaux sociaux pour
s'informer c'est d'ailleurs sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'ils ont découvert
ébahis que des élus de la République
avaient choisi ce week-end d'arborer
l'échappe l'écharpe tricolore et de se
joindre à une manifestation scandé par
des champs contre la police mais la
liberté d'expression monsieur le député
ne vaut pas liberté d'accrétion nul ne
peut impunément agressé autrui sur
Internet vous allez rappeler la
situation tragique que notre pays a vécu
depuis une semaine je le disais tout à
l'heure dans de nombreux départements le
Val-de-Marne les Hauts-de-Seine les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques l'Ille-et-Vilaine
la Haute-Savoie des individus ont été
retrouvés traduits devant la justice et
condamné à des peines de prison pour
cette livrée à des appels au meurtres de
policiers de gendarmes d'agression
contre des mers ou d'appels à détruire
des bâtiments publics des commissariats
et des gendarmeries alors oui nous avons
besoin de toutes les initiatives au
niveau européen avec le Règlement sur
les services numériques que la France a
porté les initiatives parlementaires
celles de Laurent Marc Angelli celle de
Bruno Studer celle d'Erwan Balanant
l'initiative gouvernementale avec le
projet de loi que nous portons avec
Bruno Le Maire pour sécuriser et réguler
l'espace numérique faire en sorte de
faire reculer
l'insécurité que nos concitoyens
rencontrent sur Internet restaurer leur
confiance et faire en sorte de réussir
ainsi la transition numérique
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Davy Rayman pour
le groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
on s'adresse au ministre de la Santé
monsieur Braun monsieur le ministre on
entend beaucoup parler des de la
désertification médicale dramatique qui
progresse dans l'Hexagone on entend
aussi souvent parler de l'état de santé
dès le client des populations souvent
précaires comprise petit à petit de
l'accès aux services publics du soin on
n'oublie pas compte souvent de préciser
que les plus grands déserts médicaux de
France se trouve à des milliers de
kilomètres d'ici en Guyane et à Mayotte
je vous en parlais déjà à la même
période il y a un an de ça dans un
courrier je suis ravi d'avoir enfin
l'occasion de vous parler de vive voix
monsieur le ministre la Guyane plus
précisément le centre hospitalier de
Kourou et face à une crise sociale
depuis des semaines du fait d'un projet
basé sur le CHRU mal ficelé qui met face
à face des professionnels de santé dont
nos populations ont besoin vital
monsieur le ministre tout projet médical
doit s'insérer dans une logique de
coordination des structure hospitalière
déjà existantes le projet de CHRU est
une occasion inédite pour votre
ministère de repenser l'offre de soins
sur le territoire guyanais où chaque
structure à sa place on se retrouve au
lieu de ça face à l'hôpital en grève
parce que des choix administratifs et
économiques complètement inopportuns ont
été actées sans prendre en compte ceux
qui font tourner notre cure de soins les
soignants et les et les réalités liées à
leur environnement
ah non après ma première demande de
rencontre il serait contacté que les
premières victimes de cette situation
qui est structuré le nom conjoncturelle
sont bien les citoyens citoyennes et le
personnel soignant de ce territoire
perte de chance de vivre conditions de
sous et de travail exécrables monsieur
le ministre l'urgence est de mise les
réponses sont urgentes à quand ce
rendez-vous crucial avec les Parlement
avec les parlementaires de Guyane en
attendant votre venue en Guyane afin de
prendre conscience de la situation je
vous remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
François Braun ministre de la santé et
de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député ravi d'avis riman merci de mettre
un éclairage sur la situation de nos
outre-mer et particulièrement de la
Guyane et de Mayotte qui sont des
territoires effectivement où les
difficultés de notre système de santé
sont acquisés et où la politique de
prévention doit être développée encore
plus devant les difficultés et la
paupérisation de certains territoires
alors on voit bien que certaines
décisions qui peuvent être prises dans
l'Hexagone s'adapte difficilement à ce
qui se passe dans nos territoires
d'outre-mer je pense en particulier à
toute nos travaux sur la
territorialisation qui peuvent se
comprendre dans le centre de la France
de l'Hexagone mais qui ne peuvent pas
apporter les mêmes réponses lorsqu'on
s'intéresse à des territoires qui sont
isolés la Guyane bénéficie bien sûr des
mesures d'ordre général et d'ailleurs il
faut souligner que le nombre de médecins
au cours de ces 10 dernières années a
augmenté de 73% en Guyane alors que la
population augmentait de 15% ce qui
montre aussi l'attractivité de ce
concernant la ville il y a une
structuration de l'offre de soins que
nous accompagnons avec le déploiement
depuis un an maintenant d'une nouvelle
CPTs qui n'existait pas avant et
l'augmentation du nombre de maisons de
santé pluriprofessionnelles là aussi
pour améliorer les conditions de travail
et pour que les praticiens puissent
prendre en charge plus de patients vous
avez souligné la situation de l'hôpital
je vous rejoins sur la situation de
l'hôpital universitaire de Cayenne nous
accompagnons cette universitarisation de
l'hôpital en particulier par la
rédaction d'un projet médical qui tienne
en compte l'ensemble de la problématique
du territoire et bien entendu de
l'hôpital de Kourou qui a des
difficultés financières majeures qui
sont en cours d'expertise concernant
l'établissement de Saint-Laurent du
Maroni nous avons doublé le nombre de
litres cet établissement et bien sûr il
est aussi dans cette logique de
territoire bien entendu le sujet n'est
pas épuisé et j'aurais le plaisir de
vous recevoir demain après-midi avec les
parlementaires de Guyane pour que nous
puissions approfondir ce sujet
et je réponds bien volontiers à votre
invitation je me suis rendu à Mayotte je
me rendrai en Guyane prochainement merci
beaucoup monsieur Riemann
merci le monsieur le ministre le
rendez-vous est pris donc je vous dis à
demain
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Vigier pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre dépendance
perte de compétences conflit d'intérêts
voilà le résultat de l'explosion des
dépenses de recours au cabinet de
conseils de 11 millions d'euros en 2014
elle s'établissent à 200 millions
d'euros en 2022 il serait grand temps
que votre majorité reprennent la
proposition de loi votée au Sénat
encadrant le recours de ces sociétés de
conseils en effet la Cour des comptes à
son tour poser la question de la
souveraineté de l'État face à des
consultants privés ces conclusions sont
accablantes elles font état de
véritables intrusion de ces prestataires
au cœur des missions de l'État souvent
en mépris des règles de la commande
publique et de toute rigueur financière
à l'heure où il est urgent de financer
des projets structurants et d'investir
en faveur des services publics dans les
territoires ruraux notamment comment
Haute-Loire ses dépenses exorbitantes ne
sont ni légitimes ni acceptable madame
la Première ministre la prise de
décision publique ne se sous-traitent
pas nous devons réapprendre à compter
sur une administration dévouée et sur
les 2,5 millions de fonctionnaires
attachés à leur métier aussi ma question
est simple allez vous abandonner la
conduite de nos politiques publiques à
des prestataires privés des pourvu de
légitimité démocratique je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Stanislas Guérini ministre de
la transformation et de la fonction
publique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Jean-Pierre Vigier vous nous interrogez
sur les résultats vous nous dites au
fond qu'attendez-vous pour agir mais la
réponse c'est que nous n'avons pas
attendu pour agir nous n'avons pas
attendu le rapport de la Cour des
comptes pour agir n'avons pas attendu la
commission d'enquête parlementaire pour
agir nous n'avons pas entendu attendu la
proposition de loi pour agir depuis deux
ans nous avons posé des actes
extrêmement concrets j'ai pu l'indiquer
tout à l'heure nouvelle Accord 4 pour
encadrer le recours aux prestations de
conseils toutes les recommandations des
sénateurs je lui dis elles sont
intégrées déontologie transparence
plafonnement des dépenses empêchement
d'avoir des procédures de suite sur les
dépenses de conseil transparence aussi
budgétaire création d'un jeune
budgétaire il est à la destination des
parlementaires circulaires et résultats
les résultats sont là 2021 monsieur le
député 2021 273
des millions d'euros de dépenses de
conseils en stratégie 2022 173 millions
d'euros les résultats sont là et je peux
vous dire que je le suis tous les mois
et la perspective de 2023 c'est une
trajectoire qui continuera à être une
trajectoire baissière j'essaye de vous
répondre monsieur le député en vous
apportant des éléments les plus factuels
possible alors vous nous interrogez sur
l'opportunité de poursuivre le débat
parlementaire moi je veux dire les
choses très clairement je me suis jamais
soustrait au débat parlementaire jamais
le Sénat a posé dans une niche
parlementaire la proposition de loi
chaque groupe ici dans cette hémicycle
peut en faire de même et je continuerai
j'ai été à toutes les auditions
parlementaires il y en avait certaines
récemment c'est le travail qu'on conduit
Nicolas sangsue et Marie le bec donc
nous sommes prêts au débat mais sur la
base de résultats factuels et je vous le
dis monsieur le député les résultats
sont là merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le député
200 millions d'euros de dépenses de
droits redistribuer ces crédits aux
collectivités locales elles en ont
grandement besoin
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Manon meunier
pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre la vie sur
Terre était la dernière de vos
préoccupations
vous avez été condamné pour inaction
pour le vivant le tribunal administratif
de Paris a reconnu la responsabilité de
l'État dans l'effondrement de la
biodiversité et cela fait deux semaines
maintenant et vous n'avez toujours pas
répondu aux collectif justice pour le
vivant qui a porté cette condamnation
seriez-vous plus occupés à prendre soin
des super profits de LVMH
ce serait fort dommage madame la
Première ministre car pour votre propre
survie vous êtes bien plus dépendantes
du ver de terre que de Bernard Arnault
car la biodiversité polynise nos
cultures fertilise nos sols nous permet
de respirer et son équilibre limite les
pandémies mondiales
ignorez votre condamnation c'est donc
nous condamner tous vous avez été
reconnu coupable de la pollution des
eaux souterraines par les pesticides et
de la mort de nos sols coupables de
soutenir d'abord les lobbies de
l'agrobusiness pour qui l'avenir de
l'agriculture ne rime qu'avec super
profit à leurs yeux peu importe la santé
de nos agriculteurs peu importe le
vivant pour eux le futur s'articule
autour de deux triptyque a pris par cœur
par votre Ministre phéno génétique
robotique numérique d'un côté et s
métola clore glyphosate néonicotinoïdes
ça rapporte
ça rapporte mes confidences ce n'est pas
durable madame la Première ministre les
scientifiques alertent l'État doit
investir dans la transition maintenance
si nous ne voulons pas que tout retombe
sur nos paysans nous avons besoin de
plus d'agriculteurs sur nos terres pour
le bien-être paysan pour une agriculture
qui peut composer avec les et les
rivières et tout simplement pour le
droit des générations futures à profiter
d'une nature préservée mais pour vous
qu'importe votre préoccupation reste le
profit des puissants l'histoire vous
jugera madame la Première ministre et
vous ne pourrez pas dire que vous ne
saviez pas
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Manon meunier
je ne doute pas que vous avez lu
attentivement les conclusions du
tribunal administratif du 29 juin
et vous avez noté que le tribunal
effectivement nous condamne en
constatant que malgré les engagements
pris par la France en 2009 entre 2009 et
les émissions pardon les quantités de
pesticides utilisées ont augmenté de 20%
en prenant les nombres de doses unités
20% entre 2009 et 2017 et je cite le
tribunal administratif de Paris
sans que la baisse constatée plus
récemment sur la période 2018-2020 ne
soit suffisante pour inverser la
tendance ce que le tribunal
administratif dit c'est qu'après 10 ans
de hausse continue en particulier quand
des écologistes étaient au gouvernement
de ce pays en particulier quand la
gauche était en responsabilité
depuis 2018 les chiffres de pesticides
baisse il baisse en quantité je vous
renvoie je vous renvoie au tribu dans
l'administratif 10% de baisse en moyenne
sur les trois dernières années il baisse
en gravité
93% de diminution des CMR 1 sur la
période concernée depuis 2018 et ce que
vous rappelez au lieu d'essayer de
polémiquer c'est la nécessité que nous
avons collectivement effectivement de
relancer un effort c'est les cophytos
voulus par la première ministre il y a
quelques semaines c'est ce matin à
l'occasion de la réunion de ce comité
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
que j'ai rappelé que ce jugement nous
oblig eait et que nous devions accélérer
la recherche en particulier sur les
alternatives non chimiques parce que les
pesticides sont mauvais pour la
biodiversité ils sont mauvais pour nos
sols mais ils sont aussi mauvais pour
les agriculteurs qui les épendent
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame meunier
vous condamnez toujours le gouvernement
Hollande mais laissez-moi vous rappeler
que le ministre de l'économie à l'époque
c'était Emmanuel Macron
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame meunier je comprends que les
conclusions définitives du tribunal vous
contrariez que vous essayez de vous
défausser de la responsabilité qui est
pourtant celle d'une partie de votre
camp
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Clara chassagnol
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame Isabelle Landry Rome
ministre de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes de la diversité de
l'égalité des chances lors du précédent
quinquennat nous avons permis de
nouvelles avancées dans la lutte contre
les LGBT phobies et pour l'égalité des
droits avec la formation de référents
dans les commissariats et les
gendarmeries avec l'ouverture de la PMA
à toutes les femmes l'interdiction des
thérapies de conversion ou encore
l'ouverture du don du sang dans les
mêmes conditions pour les personnes
homosexuelles et hétérosexuelles l'année
dernière à l'occasion des 40 ans de la
dépénalisation de l'homosexualité 3
millions d'euros ont été octroyés pour
les centrales GBT et un ambassadeur à la
légalité des droits a été nommée malgré
ses évolutions les attentes commises en
raison de l'orientation sexuelle ou de
l'identité de genre sont en augmentation
alors que 20% des victimes d'agression
déposeraient plaintes et seulement 5%
des victimes d'injures ces violences
existent dans tous les territoires de
l'hexagone et des Outre-mer où la N peut
s'exprimer dans le milieu scolaire
l'espace public le cercle familial le
sport ou encore sur sur les réseaux
sociaux pour ceux qui se pensent dans
l'impunité récemment des dégradations de
centrales LGBT ont eu lieu à La Réunion
à Tours à Perpignan et lors des émeutes
qui ont émaillé le pays des médias ont
révélé une conversation de jeunes à
Brest appelant à la violence contre un
bar LGBT nous devons encore mener ce
combat de sensibilisation dans tous les
secteurs de la société pour que les
personnes LGBT vivent librement et
dignement sans la crainte du mépris le
plan 2023 2026 que vous avez présenté
hier a fait l'objet de large
consultation en partenariat avec les
associations et je tiens à vous
remercier pour votre engagement et votre
écoute à leur côté comme hier au siège
de SOS Homophobie vous avez pris le
temps d'échanger avec les bénévoles sur
les annonces du plan aussi madame la
ministre pouvez-vous nous détailler les
mesures concrètes qui permettront de
changer les mentalités et de sanctionner
les auteurs d'injures et d'agressions
partout où elles ont lieu pour que les
personnes LGBT ne soient plus les cibles
de la haine je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame Isabelle
roministre chargée de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes et de la
diversité et de l'égalité des chances
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
cher Clara chassagnoles oui la haine
anti LGBT plus persiste et cela malgré
le considérable avancé initié par le
Président de la République depuis 2017
et trop peu de personnes déposent
plaintes vous l'avez dit il nous faut
intensifier notre action mieux
identifier mieux prévenir mieux traiter
cette haine c'est le sens du plan
gouvernemental dévoiley hier que je que
je porte lutter contre la haine c'est
d'abord faire appliquer le droit c'est
aussi mettre fin à toute impunité cela
passe par le renforcement des formations
des forces de l'ordre 100% d'entre elles
seront formées
2024 cela passe aussi par une répression
efficace des actes et des propos
homophobes non les propos homophobes
tenus dans les stades ne sont pas des
manifestations de liesse populaire ce
sont des actes d'incitation à la haine
des actes d'incitation à la violence ce
sont des délits qui doivent qui seront
sanctionnés systématiquement par une
peine complémentaire d'interdiction des
stades mais cela passe aussi par un
renforcement et un éveil des consciences
c'est pour cela que nous avons un plan
de formation massif à l'égard des
professionnels des santé des professeurs
des agents publics des personnels de
santé des encadrants de colonies de
vacances et puis dans notre société
aucun jeûne ne doit être abandonné aucun
jeune de doit se sentir rejeté
nous ouvrirons 10 nouveaux centres
d'accueil pour les personnes LGBT plus
sur l'ensemble du territoire d'ici la
fin du quinquennat deux par région c'est
une enveloppe de 10 millions d'euros qui
prévus à cet effet dans la suite des
annonces de la première ministre et
d'ailleurs je vous invite mesdames et
messieurs les députés à défend la
création de telle sorte sur le
territoire merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
vous avez préparé vos éléments de
langage sur notre participation à une
manifestation interdite que les immenses
Martin Luther King Gandhi Mandela nous
regarde plus proche que les militants
d'une Algérie indépendante nous écoutent
eux qui ont bravé tous les interdits
pour manifester au nom de la justice
laissons ces personnages à l'histoire la
Constitution garantit le droit de
manifester en sécurité vous en faites un
usage politique vous interdisez les
manifestations écologiques les
manifestations
antiracistes les milices d'extrême
droite elle ne déposent pas
d'autorisation avant leur manifestation
alors vous les laissez à l'écart de vos
critiques
qu'y a-t-il de commun entre la
répression violente des gilets jaunes la
restestation
et menaces contre le jeune sous les
manne et dénonciation d'exactions
violentes au moment de la mobilisation
des réformes des retraites je vous aide
la brave m une unité dont est issue le
policier qui a tiré sur Naël une unité
visée par plusieurs enquêtes judiciaires
alors évidemment il y a beaucoup
d'enquêtes contre cette brave m dont
certains mandiennes de la CSI 93 la
merci la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer merci madame la Présidente et
Monsieur députés madame la député
Rousseau permettez-moi si vous me le
permettez pardon je suis un peu fatigué
de vous corriger ce n'est pas dépêcher
la bravèmes qui ont tiré sur le jeune
conducteur de Nanterre ce sont des
policiers de la DOPC sur des motards du
92 je pense que dans votre démonstration
vous avez vous avez manifestement
confondu des choses
par ailleurs par ailleurs madame madame
la députée je crois que vous payez un
peu de mots que Gandhi et Mandela vous
regarde je crois c'est un peu excessif
en revanche les Français vous vous
regardent et je regrette madame la
députée ce tweet du 7 juillet que vous
avez depuis supprimer la police ne peut
ne doit pas tuer jamais cette apprécie
simple un principe républicain le tir
même en cas de terrorisme ne doit pas
être l'option privilégiée
il ne peut exister que dans des cas
extrêmes madame la député c'est dommage
qu'il ne vous reste pas quelques
secondes je vous aurais posé la question
est-ce que vous pensez que le terrorisme
est ou pas un cas extrême pour les
policiers
j'ai aussi lu ce tweet que vous n'avez
pas retiré malheureusement
sur le slogan tout le monde déteste la
police je l'ai entendu dans des cortège
d'hiver retraite après Sainte-Souline
dans des manifs écolos à la marche pour
Naëlle et hier pour Adama c'est une
alerte quand des milices ou des
manifestations d'extrême droite crie
tout le monde déteste étranger alors
appelle-t-il de notre part une réflexion
non madame il faut condamner on sait
propos qui sont un crime contre la
pensée troisièmement madame Brussels 30
juin vous n'avez toujours pas retirer ce
tweet non plus et si le pillage avait
avoir avec la pauvreté quelle insulte
envers les pauvres quelle insulte envers
les classes modestes qui tous les jours
travaillent au le goût de l'effort et
l'éducation pour avoir une lecture de
classe sociale de ce qui se passe
madame Rousseau ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas Gandhi et ce n'est pas Mandela qui
vous regarde c'est vos électeurs qui
doivent se dire c'est vos électeurs qui
doivent se dire qu'ils se sont peut-être
trompés
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Michael boulot
pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre l'été
dernier a été le plus chaud jamais
enregistré en Europe 2,3 degrés
au-dessus des normales cela a causé
61672 morts suivant une étude entre le
30 mai et le 4 septembre 2022 sur le
continent européen
les chercheurs de l'Inserm ont par
ailleurs démontré que la France est le
pays qui a enregistré la plus forte
augmentation des températures par
rapport au moyen de saisons plus 2,43°c
et notre pays arrive en quatrième
position quand le nombre de décès avec
4807 morts liés à cette chaleur
selon les dernières données récentes de
l'Organisation météorologique mondiale
la trajectoire des températures de 2023
s'emballe et particulièrement
inquiétante
nous pouvons parler d'une catastrophe
sanitaire et les premières victimes sont
les populations les plus précaires qui
vivent pour ne pas dire survivre dans
des passoires thermiques il y a plus
d'un mois Selma ma fouse et Jean Pisani
Ferri rendaient un rapport sans appel
appelant à une programmation pour un
investissement climat sur 3 décennies et
préconisant de mettre en place un impôt
exceptionnel et temporaire sur les
patrimoines financiers des Français les
plus aisés à hauteur de 5 milliards
d'euros par an pour participer au 30
milliards d'euros annuels nécessaires de
dépenses publiques supplémentaires sur
ces sujets la décarbonation est un sujet
qui touche à la survie de l'humanité on
est face à un mur et ce mur il faut
trouver les moyens de le financer
chacun doit prendre sa part selon ses
revenus ces mots sont ceux de Jean
Pisani Ferri quand est-il aujourd'hui
madame la Première ministre de la mise
en oeuvre du nécessaire fiscalité
écologique planifiée tourner résolument
vers la justice sociale il s'agit
d'accélérer les dépenses climatiques
nécessaires à toutes et tous par de
nouveaux moyens merci merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Michael boulot
de choses d'abord vous avez cité le
rapport de Monsieur Pisani Ferri et de
madame mafouze qui chiffre la hauteur de
la marche et le premier élément il a été
apporté par la première milice ce
week-end avec les augmentations de
crédit à hauteur de 7 milliards nous
parlons au crédit de paiement pas en
autorisation d'engagement le budget
permettra de montrer en particulier
qu'en matière de ferroviaire il y a des
dépenses qu'il faut qu'on engage
maintenant même si elle ne trouve pas de
crédit dès l'année 2024 et donc c'est
bien sur la base de ces 60 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires que nous devons
trouver que nous construisons la feuille
de route sous l'autorité d'Elisabeth
band de la planification écologique
le financement il repose sur une
pluralité l'acteur y compris comme le
dit le rapport plusani ferry aussi sur
les entreprises privées sur la capacité
pour elle d'engager des dépenses de
transition et sur une évolution à budget
constant d'une partie des dépenses
publiques et puis nous avons des surplus
de crédit à mettre en particulier sur la
rénovation énergétique et sur les
transports où nous savons la hauteur des
besoins et la réalité qu'il y a
l'ambition du gouvernement c'est de
faire en sorte que ce soit en fonction
des émissions que nous puissions
augmenter les contributions et je vous
renvoie à la décision que nous avons
pris il y a seulement quelques mois
d'augmenter de 70% la fiscalité du
kérosène pour précisément l'aligner sur
l'essence de manière à faire en sorte
que les avions et en particulier les
plus petits d'entre eux soit taxés de la
même manière que les voitures ça n'est
qu'un premier pas dans le cadre du
verdissement des dépenses nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir sur un certain
nombre de dépenses brunes
toujours autour de l'aviation autour des
sociétés autoroutières et dispositif de
ce type je vous donne rendez-vous dans
quelques mois merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
monsieur boulot vous avez trois secondes
oui mais que ferons tous les plus aisés
sur une planète brûlée il faut les faire
contribuer merci
[Applaudissements]
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique monsieur le
ministre c'est le député de
Saint-Étienne qui vous interroge
aujourd'hui au niveau national que mal
international nous connaissons la loi et
plus spécifiquement Saint-Étienne pour
son club de foot mythique pour son
histoire minière et industrielle avec sa
manufacture d'armes et Manu France
notamment avec le design satiété son
école avec une solidarité exceptionnelle
qui se traduit notamment par une vie
associative forte et par le groupe
Casino oui le groupe Casino cette marque
de grande distribution créée par la
famille Guichard Perrachon qui est si
connu et si aimé par des Français
car Casino a toujours placé les
consommateurs au cœur de sa politique et
de ses innovations ce sont les salariés
du Groupe Casino qui ont inventé le
libre-service puis les chaînes de froid
et même les dates limites de vente
Casino est un groupe qui s'est construit
à Saint-Étienne et Saint-Étienne est une
ville qui s'est bâtie autour du groupe
Casino au siège social ce ne sont pas
moins de 2000 employés qui travaillent
au cœur du quartier d'affaires de
Châteaucreux
salarié syndicat et le locaux
parlementaires habitants nous sommes
tous d'accord pour dire que casino fait
partie du patrimoine stéphanois
malheureusement le groupe Casino se
trouve aujourd'hui dans une situation
financière très difficile en cessation
de paiement virtuel grâce au report des
échéances fiscales et sociales accordées
par l'État et je tiens pour ceci à vous
remercier très fortement monsieur le
ministre le 3 juillet dernier deux
offres de reprise ont été concrétisées
et à ce stade aucune garantie n'a été
apportée pour le siège de Saint-Étienne
l'inquiétude des salariés mais aussi des
Stéphanois et grandissantes pour ces
raisons monsieur le ministre je vous
demande quels sont vos intentions pour
conserver le siège social et les
activités du Groupe Casino à
Saint-Étienne merci beaucoup mon cher
mes collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire ministre de l'Économie
des Finances de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Quentin bataillon comme vous
l'avez très bien dit le groupe Casino
rencontre depuis plusieurs mois des
difficultés opérationnelles et
financières majeures il a accumulé 6,5
milliards d'euros de dettes mettant en
péril dans les semaines qui viennent son
activité et les 50 000 emplois qui sont
en jeu face à cette situation nous avons
pris la décision d'autoriser le groupe
Casino à reporter le paiement de ses
charges sociales et fiscales c'est une
aide de 300 millions d'euros que nous
avons ainsi apporté au groupe Casino
cette tête devra évidemment être
remboursé par les repreneurs à l'état
sur cette base des reprises des
propositions de reprise ont pu être
faites deux propositions ont été faites
ces deux propositions sont solides mais
l'État n'a pas à prendre parti pour une
proposition de reprise ou pour une autre
en revanche je veux être très clair sur
les deux points d'attention qui seront
les nôtres le premier c'est la solidité
du projet industriel Casino est un beau
groupe un groupe solide avec des actifs
répartis à travers tout le territoire
avec des salariés qui font un travail
formidable et qui n'ont pas à payer pour
les erreurs qui ont pu être commises par
la direction du groupe donc nous serons
attentifs à la solidité du projet
industriel des deux repreneurs le
deuxième sujet sur lequel nous serons
très attentifs vous l'avez dit vous-même
c'est l'avenir des 50 000 salariés du
groupe répartis sur tout le territoire
et l'avenir des 1500 salariés du groupe
AS Saint-Étienne le siège historique de
casino vous l'avez rappelé il n'est pas
question que le siège historique du
groupe soit menacé par la reprise du
groupe quel que soit le repreneur qui
sera choisi à l'issue de ce processus
donc vous le voyez soutient de l'État
report de charge de propositions qui
sont choisies sur la table l'État sera
vigilant sur l'emploi et sur le siège de
Saint-Etienne auquel je sais chaque
Quantin bataillon vous êtes très attaché
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Annick cousin pour
le groupe rassemblement national merci
madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre un rapport de la Cour
des Comptes publié hier mais en évidence
une fois encore les dérives concernant
le recours au cabinet de conseil durant
la gouvernance d'Emmanuel Macron le
recours à ses cabinets de conseils
privés parfois étrangers a
considérablement augmenter au cours des
10 dernières années passant de 11
millions d'euros en une 2014
à 103 millions en 2018 pour atteindre
200 millions en 2022 ces chiffres
n'incluent pas les prestations dans le
domaine informatique qui sont elles
parfois utiles non je parle des deux
pains de dépenses plutôt plus
contestable une telle intrusion du
secteur privé dans la gestion des
affaires publiques soulève des
interrogations une question de
transparence de
prévention des conflits d'intérêts
d'abord une question de confiance en
notre hôte administration ensuite en
effet des missions demandées sont
souvent identiques à celles assumées par
les
hauts corps d'inspection et de contrôle
de la République et enfin une question
ne maîtrise de l'argent public et de
l'argent du contribuable de la part d'un
gouvernement qui se prétend bon
gestionnaire
car comment justifier un paiement à prix
d'or par exemple d'une étude visage site
à réfléchir à l'évolution du métier
d'enseignant ou encore à réorganiser la
Direction Générale de l'Enseignement
scolaire nos enseignants ne sont-ils pas
compétents pour réfléchir à l'évolution
de leur métier nos fonctionnaires non
plus ma question madame la Première
ministre et la suivante nous avons une
haute administration parmi les plus
réputés du monde pourquoi une telle
défiance à l'égard de la haute fonction
publique française et comment justifier
vous cela je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Stanislas Guerini ministre de
la transformation et de la fonction
publique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
les députés Annick cousin au fond votre
question et son lot de démagogie qui
l'accompagnait ne me surprend guère de
la part de votre famille politique parce
que ce qui vous intéresse ce sont
davantage les polémiques les problèmes
les gros titres que quand nous apportons
des solutions ce qui marche ce qui
progresse ça nous intéresse assez peu
alors puisque vous m'avez interrogé au
fond sur la question de la
réinternalisation de compétences qui est
une question effectivement stratégique
et que j'ai toujours regardé en face et
bien je vais vous répondre sur cette
question sur la ligne du gouvernement la
ligne du gouvernement quand on recourt
aux prestations externes de conseils
elle est extrêmement claire est-ce que
c'est indigne en soi que le gouvernement
puisse recourir à une prestation de
conseils externe la réponse c'est non
évidemment non quand nous devons
réfléchir à des sujets structurant à des
sujets qui requiert des compétences
extrêmement pointues qui ne sont pas
toujours les administrations alors
parfois oui bien sûr et ce n'est pas une
réponse démagogique que de vous dire ça
cela peut se justifier ça donne des
résultats ça permet par exemple d'aller
chercher les meilleurs experts pour
travailler sur des questions
d'intelligence artificielle mais est-ce
que ce gouvernement agit agit résolument
pour réinterniser des compétences la
réponse est évidemment oui et nous le
faisons et si vous le faisait votre
travail de parlementaire vous pouvez
vérifier cela dans le budget il est à la
disposition de tous les parlementaires
nous avons dès l'année 2022
réinternaliser 15 postes au sein de la
Direction intermède la transformation
publique mais à chaque fois ça ne vous
intéresse pas nous allons continuer
cette trajectoire là 20 postes
supplémentaires pour l'année 2023 c'est
débats vous pourrez les avoir faites
votre travail de parlementaire et vous
le verrez nous progressons
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
madame la députée vos cabinets de
conseils monsieur le ministre coûte un
pognon de dingue et ce sont toujours les
Français qui payent
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Emmanuel Fernandez pour le
groupe la France insoumise
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire qui disait
d'Emmanuel Macron avant un spectaculaire
retournement de vestes un sport
collectif en macronie qu'il était
l'homme sans projet et sans conviction
et bien si Emmanuel Macron avait bien un
projet que vous mettez en œuvre avec
brio enrichir les plus riches selon la
presse économique la fortune cumulée des
500 Français les plus riches s'élèvent
désormais à 1170 milliards d'euros soit
45% du PIB un record oui vous ne rêvez
pas les 500 plus riches possèdent
l'équivalent de près de la moitié des
richesses produites par l'ensemble du
pays en une année
c'était seulement si l'on peut dire un
quart en 2017 à l'arrivée d'Emmanuel
Macron au pouvoir et 10% du PIB en 2009
une vraie success story pour le bien
nommé président des riches mais comme le
disait Victor Hugo c'est de l'enfer des
pauvres qui a fait le paradis des riches
en effet les mêmes pages économiques
indique que depuis janvier 2022 le
volume des dépenses alimentaires a chuté
de 17% dans le pays en raison de
l'inflation du jamais vu depuis 1980 oui
une part croissante de la population n'a
plus les moyens de se nourrir
suffisamment or dans une note de
l'Institut La Boétie parue hier on
apprend que 70% de la hausse des prises
alimentaires est dû au bénéfice des
entreprises agroalimentaires qui en
profiter de la guerre en Ukraine pour
faire accepter des hausses injustifiées
ainsi qu'à la grande distribution qui a
augmenté ses marges sur des produits de
première nécessité
en versant toujours plus de dividendes
et surprise on retrouve les actionnaires
de ces entreprises dans les 500 plus
grandes fortunes alors Monsieur le
Ministre plutôt que d'organiser la
famine pour gaver vos amis quand
partagerez-vous enfin les richesses
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des petits et moyens d'entreprise du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
monsieur le député faire landaise votre
question
alors c'est pas facile en deux minutes
de répondre à la fois aux dividendes au
profit
à la précarité alimentaire en fait c'est
un si tenté que éventuellement la
réponse vous intéresse éventuellement je
vais essayer de répondre
et c'est vrai qu'on voilà j'ai eu le
sentiment d'avoir un beau pot-au-feu
c'est sympa l'été mais ça mélange quand
même des choses qui n'ont absolument
rien à voir Monsieur le Député donc je
vais vous répondre déjà sur l'inflation
alimentaire mais encore une fois si
tenter que la réponse vous intéresse
sinon je vous fais pas perdre de temps
et moi non plus
l'inflation alimentaire monsieur elle
est en baisse si ça vous intéresse
l'inflation alimentaire française elle
est en baisse elle est aujourd'hui à
moins de 14% ça fait trois mois
d'affilée qu'elle est en baisse et je
vous rappelle que dans cette poussée
inflationniste la France s'en est plutôt
bien sorti il faut regarder un petit peu
ce qui se passe peut-être en Espagne ce
qui se passe en Allemagne ce qui se
passe sur des mesures qui s'y tentaient
que la réponse vous intéresse il y a des
mesures qui ont été prises et
l'inflation par exemple en Espagne
demeure très élevée par rapport à des
propositions qui ont été mises en place
comme la suppression de la TVA vous avez
proposé le blocage des prix sur
l'inflation alimentaire ça ne marche pas
monsieur ça crée de la créer de la
précarité ça crée de la précarité
beaucoup d'exemples nous l'ont démontré
et ça ne permet pas au plus fragile de
s'en sortir alors plutôt que de pérorer
plutôt que de pérorer
en réalité ce qui est important
alors madame la Présidente panneau
en fait
si ça vous intéresse vous aurez un point
extrêmement précis sur les centaines de
produits dont les prix en baissés parce
que pendant que vous papotez et vous
faites votre notoriété sur la fragilité
des gens nous on travaille l'inflation
alimentaire elle baisse et notre pays
n'a pas un rougir on a accompagné comme
personne les plus fragiles pendant la
crise et plutôt que de faire du beurre
avec on essaye de les accompagner je
vous remercie beaucoup madame la
ministre la séance des questions
gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue